this is Jocko podcast number 362. with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening so I was an
officer candidate School
1998. uh it's a form of military
indoctrination I was already in the
military I had already been
indoctrinated in the military
so as I was going through it I could
kinda
a little bit more detached you know I
could see a little bit more had a little
bit more experience
and there's all kinds of procedures and
protocols that you have to follow when
you're going officer candidate School
you gotta you gotta fold your underwear
into a five inch by five inch square for
a locker inspection you've got a med
they come in measure it with a steel
ruler the drill instructors Marine Corps
drone instructors they have a they have
like their own personal
you know some somebody has a possession
that you can see it kind of has a
certain level of Pride to it they would
have these steel rulers and slap it down
on that thing
and they're going to measure your
handkerchief and your t-shirts and all
this stuff and it's about attention
detail
which is cool it's about protocols
learning protocols and and inspecting
each other so as a team so you might
check my locker and we're trying to help
each other out but one thing that always
stuck stuck with me on the protocol
level was the belt buckle that you had
so you could issue this belt buckle
and this belt buckle when you get issued
it it's shiny gold
and it's it's shiny gold it's probably
brass actually but then there's a a
clear enamel coat on it
and what that means is you can buy this
thing and it won't just tarnish because
it's got this really
strong clear enamel coat on it's very
thin but that's what keeps it from
tarnishing
but you can still get fingerprints on
the enamel so you could have a belt
buckle that has like a fingerprint on it
or a smudge on it so you would wipe them
off you you kind of like wipe down your
your belt buckle
now here's the thing
at some point this had evolved to where
you would take your belt buckle that had
this enamel on it
and you would polish it
until the enamel was gone
and so now and now it could tarnish so
you remove the protective layer so that
it could tarnish this so something that
started as a good idea which is you buff
the belt buckle so there's no
fingerprints on it
escalated over time to where you were
polishing this thing
until all the enamel was removed and now
it would tarnish more easily and it's
actually hard to take care of now
so this this thing that started with
good intent oh you're gonna make sure
there's no fingerprints on it turned
into craziness
[Laughter]
and people no one knows where it started
like no one knows when it got stupid
and no one knows we ended up when we
ended up at officer candidate School
making people do something stupid but we
did it and this can happen with anything
now there's a there's a similar term in
or I shouldn't say in a similar
situation there's a term in political
discourse called the Overton window
the Overton window which was this is
originated this term was originated by a
guy that was named Joseph Overton who is
a political scientist and a like a
Libertarian type dude
and
he actually died flying an ultralight at
age 43 but
this idea of the Overton window is that
there's a there's a window
in the acceptance of ideas
so ideas go through a transition so
let's say there's an idea out there it
starts off when the idea first comes to
light it's totally unthinkable
totally Unthinkable meaning totally
unacceptable
and then it actually as people talk
about it more and it becomes more
familiar it goes from being Unthinkable
or totally unacceptable to just radical
like so you're not saying oh that's
unacceptable you're just saying oh
that's that's pretty radical
and then eventually it moves to being
like a fringe idea but now it's moving
into the acceptable category
then eventually it becomes acceptable
and then it becomes sensible and then it
becomes popular and then it eventually
becomes policy
and there's a bunch of things that kind
of
we've watched go through this Evolution
I mean tattoos right tattoos years ago
tattoos were
kind of unacceptable in normal society
it was like bikers
bikers had tattoos and and convicts had
tattoos it wasn't normal now
the tattoos are basically totally
acceptable
long hair for men
which I don't support
but but hey but long hair for men in the
1940s totally unacceptable
in the
1950s and 60s it was in the 50s it was
like radical
in the 60s it was like kind of normal
now it's just
acceptable
so as people
push the envelope with behavior the
Overton window expands and Things become
more acceptable and Norms change over
time
and it's also true that as one part of
the overtone window opens another part
closes so years ago if you were firing
someone because they had a tattoo or you
fired someone because they had long hair
now that would be unacceptable okay well
the guy had long hair you can't just
fire someone because they have long hair
that wouldn't be unacceptable now
so
what am I talking about how do these two
things relate the belt buckle in the
Overton window well
it certainly seems to me
that as we look at the way Society is
evolving today
the Overton window of what's acceptable
has
expanded
and moved so much
that
it it might not make sense anymore what
some things that are now not only
acceptable but now sort of getting
pushed you wonder if they're if they
make sense and maybe they could actually
even be harmful
and I think if we if we as people aren't
careful
we can kind of slowly drift around
inside that Overton window from the
positive of having an open mind
to
to an extreme to where there's no more
guard rails there's no more framework
and there's no more Baseline of what's
acceptable and what's isn't
so a friend of mine
it seems to me has been trying to
maintain some kind of Sanity some kind
of rationality to the expansion of the
Overton window to apply some baseline to
the world
and I think it's been a pretty good
fight for her I think she's just getting
warmed up uh she's a former
congresswoman she's a former
presidential candidate she's an army
officer Iraq war veteran podcaster
a surfer martial artist
and Hawaiian
she's been on this podcast before
episode 272 her name is Tulsi gabbard
and it's an honor to have her back with
us tonight
Tulsi gabbard
Aloha how's it going
there's been a lot of there's been a lot
going on in your world yeah it's been
crazy it's been kind of crazy to watch
when you came on this podcast for the
first time
um you were a democratic I don't know if
you were running for president were you
running for president at the time I
think
um if I'm not mistaken this was in late
um I don't know I should attack church
so I think the
um if I'm not mistaken I think the
presidential campaign was finished at
that point in time and we were talking
about how it went yeah yeah well it's
it's always interesting to me because I
have some of my friends are uh dope dope
smoking hippies some of them are
right-wing conservative fundamentalist
Christians and everything in between and
when you came on my podcast
you know some of the the first time you
came on the some of my super
conservative friends were like yo
why are you giving her a platform I was
like oh cause she's cool and I like her
and then some of my dope smoking hippie
friends were like hell yeah that's what
I'm talking about
so you you know you you had sort of a
I think you had a a reputation or an
image I think and you more than that I
think you just get categorized right you
were a Democrat at the time which I know
you aren't anymore yep uh so what
happened man what happened let's talk
about that so you left the Democratic
party yeah
well first of all just say um
for as long as I've been in politics
people who like to put other humans in
categories have always had trouble
putting me in a category
um just because I've always been a very
independent-minded person so you know I
first ran for office in 2002 in Hawaii I
was 21 years old very passionate about
environmental issues and protecting the
beauty of our home in Hawaii the water
oceans and and that was my motivation to
run for state house and you know prior
to that point I had no
like familial political affiliation
there was no like you know my daddy and
granddaddy were Democrats so I have to
be a Democrat my parents were very like
hey you you go make your own decisions
figure out
you know what what is your foundational
principles and so at that time
I I really had to look because I had to
you know filed a piece of paper saying
I'm running for office and there was a
box to check like okay fine what part
are you gonna run under
and so I started looking at um kind of
the origins of in Hawaii the Democratic
party Hawaii had been under the rule of
a few very wealthy Republicans uh since
it became a territory of the United
States and then later through statehood
and the shift towards Democratic
politics in Hawaii came about because
um of Plantation workers people who are
being treated like crap like in in uh
inhumane conditions being paid pennies
for working
super long hours it was it was basically
like glorified slave labor and so it was
the Democratic Party in the ILWU that
came in it was like no this is not okay
and and so it was the party that in our
history in Hawaii was the big tent
inclusive party it was the party for the
people it was the party that stood up
against those few very wealthy people in
power and said no you can't just abuse
people like this uh it was the party
that stood for civil liberties and
individual freedom and choice like hey
whatever your personal choice is whether
it's free speech or freedom of religion
or whatever it is like
Live and Let Live we can disagree
without being disagreeable and so I
looked at the party in Hawaii and I
looked at leaders like JFK and Dr Martin
Luther King and I was drawn to the
Democratic party for those reasons
because again in my as I looked at
Hawaii as like these Super Rich
Republican dudes have been abusing their
power to fill their pockets at the
expense of the well-being of the people
and so fast forward
um
I left the Democrat Party because all of
those things that I just talked about
are gone the leaders of today's
Democratic party don't believe in
um
really into Freedom basically what it
comes down to and you look at that
freedom of choice freedom of speech uh
freedom of religion and
um
you know there's a lot of other issues
that that I could get into But
ultimately how do you have a political
party that's in power
that doesn't believe in Freedom and is
actively taking action to undermine our
Constitution and Bill of Rights
and that was really what was at the the
Crux of of why I left
um the Democrat Party was there a straw
that broke the camel's back
there wasn't one single moment but it
was really over the last like few years
two three years seeing this increasing
um
like quickly escalating towards
um policies coming from our government
that really frankly were becoming
increasingly authoritarian
and so you know it caused me to kind of
spend time reflecting and being
introspective like wait hold on a second
and people saying like how can you still
be how can you call yourself a Democrat
and I was obviously have like I said
I've always been an independent-minded
person I I've been critical of people in
power uh whether they're Republicans Or
democrats and also complimentary when I
felt like they did things that were good
for the country but
um
you know looking looking at at the
dangerous combination of what we've seen
over the last few years especially of
people in power who don't believe in the
Constitution who openly question things
like the first amendment and right to
free speech coupled with oh by the way
they control and are politicizing
agencies like the Department of Justice
and the FBI and Department of Homeland
Security
uh sicking the domestic newly formed
domestic Terror unit of the Department
of Homeland Security on parents like
protesting at Board of Education
meetings because they're like well we
don't agree with what you guys are
trying to teach our young kids at school
and and to see that playing out before
our eyes and this Culture of Fear where
if you speak out against this stuff and
and call it for what it is
you are immediately labeled
anti-authority
and also therefore coming from our
government an extremist and a Potential
Threat
a potential domestic threat and so
that's why you're talking about the the
Overton window and you and you look at
like okay well you take people having
open minds and like okay well I can
consider you know someone else's
perspective even if I don't agree with
it which is how things should be in
general
and then you take it to that next level
where you're saying well there are no
guard rails anymore and this is what's
so dangerous is is when you have
again people are entitled to their own
opinions but when you have people in
positions of power in this country who
deny the existence of objective truth
as they are then where where is like
where's the floor where's the guard
rails where is the ceiling how do you
measure anything well it's like okay
well whatever's true is whatever they
say is true
but then what happens when when they're
gone and the next person or group of
people come in or the next party and
then what if they don't agree with what
that group says is true or false and and
so um and then you couple that with the
Fear Factor and cancel culture and and
people literally seeing what happens to
people like me where you you just say
like hey well this is what's happening
and it's crazy it's insane and then I
get called all kinds of names and all
kinds of stuff uh all kinds of attacks
and so no wonder so many people are
afraid
to do the equivalent of like uh yeah
obviously the emperor has no clothes
like we can all see it and there's a lot
of concern about what's happening but so
few people feel like they have the
ability to speak up without being
worried about losing their job or being
shunned by friends or family members or
being like that crazy person
um and so this is this is kind of one
thing that's been that's been
interesting and and hope inspiring is is
you know I put out this this kind of
long and end up statement talking about
some of these very specific examples of
what's wrong with today's Democrat party
and I've been hearing from a lot of
people people I know a lot of people I
don't know in person on social media
people just saying like
like in a really serious and heavy kind
of way thank you for bringing voice to
the things that I've been feeling and
been frustrated with and but you know
haven't been able to give voice to
and uh so my hope is that you know the
more we speak up the more people feel as
though they can speak up and uh
yeah how do we protect people how do we
protect our freedoms that are under
attack by exercising them
yeah I was you know I was like to like
cover a book on this podcast when you
were coming on I said I was thinking
about covering the book
Rules for Radicals by Saul Alinsky uh
this is a book you know this is a guy
that uh this is a book that Hillary
Clinton wrote her thesis on when she
graduated from college but there's some
of those rules
one of the one of the rules is hold them
to their own rules right and that's what
what you're talking about when you say
hey this is America we have an open mind
and so you go okay cool then you have to
accept everything right that's like one
of those things you can't say anything
negative about anybody anytime or you're
you're not following your own rules
You're Something phobic right right
everything is something phobic you just
add whatever it is at the beginning of
it yeah and another one of the rules
that he talks about is the power of
ridicule so when you just go on a an
obliterating attack on a person it's
overwhelming for them and it works and
it's worked a lot to to shut people down
and shut them up and that's a
you can see some of these the way that
these these rules are implemented and
and that's another thing you know as I
talk about that
that uh belt buckle thing and you don't
know where it came from and there's a
bunch of things like that in the middle
there's a bunch of traditions you go
what are we this is stupid why are we
doing this
and you do and people don't really know
where it came from and I think some of
the things that are going on with
Society right now if you start to
pull the thread on where it actually
initiated a lot of it did initiate in
like the radicals the Communists and the
60s that we're trying to trying to make
their impact
and I I honestly don't think a lot of
people that are fully on that on board
with that program know where it came
from today they're just doing what they
kind of learned yeah because that was
you know a big goal was to take over the
universities which obviously they did a
pretty good job pretty good job take it
over the universities what is it the
University's vote 99 something like 99
Democratic in universities that that's
obviously you're not going to get a very
balanced education if that's what you're
going through
and then the scary thing is and this is
another thing we've talked about a bit
on this podcast
and it is the
just the the complete
plasticity of people's brains and how
people can you get into an echo chamber
or you get you start following and
listening to certain things
it's going to take over your mind
and that's really really scary and
you know I I've been saying lately like
everyone's getting brainwashed I'm
getting brainwashed right now like
that's what's happening if you're
watching if you're listening if you're
opening your mind and letting other
things in there you're gaining
brainwashed you're and that's what's
happening to everybody all the time
that's what this I mean it's sort of
like it's a combination of brainwashing
and learning right if you're learning
you're kind of getting brainwashed
you're you're bringing in new ideas
but then you see people that are
learning ideas that aren't
essentially they're not good they're not
healthy and it's very very disturbing
and especially nowadays where that
brainwashing is in your pocket and at
any moment you can pull it out and you
can you can get brainwashed at any
moment and it's really really scary
um
and especially you know the the
moldability of children yeah
14 year olds 12 year olds 19 years old
you know it's like when I joined the
military
you're going to get brainwashed to some
level
I got in trouble when I went to boot
camp
um well exercises actually I didn't get
in trouble because they didn't know who
said it they we had to fill out a form
like about how boot camp was going but
it was Anonymous and they wrote
something like you know what do you
think of the program so far and I wrote
uh the brainwashing has been very
effective that's what I wrote how old
are you at the time
19 okay 18 or 19. yeah and
um
you know it's because I had a very
rebellious mind you know because I was
like what was I brainwashed by I was
brainwashed before I joined the military
by hardcore music and punk rock and like
anti-authoritarianism and so for me they
were trying to hit me with that stuff
and I kind of had some good resistance
to it so I kind of like oh they're
trying to brainwash me and then I kind
of made a joke about it the brainwashing
has been you know effective thus far
which that's what they're trying to do
they're trying to get you to like change
your brain a little bit and think in a
different way and and uh but at least I
I think I think I always had that
rebellious streak in me that always
questions everything and to this day
when I see something online I'm like oh
what's their angle yeah what's the angle
over there because there's everyone's
got an angle everyone does which is
which is disturbing
and um yeah so this is what's happening
now with kids and you can see it and
it's sad yeah it's so sad to see I
listened to a podcast that you did uh on
your podcast which is called the Tulsi
gabbard show with uh
was it is it called de-transitioning
yeah with Chloe Cole that was horrifying
exactly it was absolutely horrifying
um give us a quick brief on her so Chloe
Cole
um and I'm glad you mentioned that
because it's a perfect example of what
you're talking about here uh she grew up
in here in California
she was a tomboy as a kid growing up uh
love playing video games loved hanging
out with their brothers
and at 11 years old she got a smartphone
start an Instagram account
she was a tomboy didn't have many female
friends didn't really fit in much at
school so was looking for
some kind of companionship uh friendship
sense of belonging online
and the algorithms on Instagram
specifically she talks about immediately
started feeding her
um hosts and and accounts of of young
girls and women who had who are
identifying as boys or men who are trans
or talking about how much happier they
were by doing so and and all of this and
then she had people around her who were
telling her well like if you're not
happy as you are then you're obviously a
boy stuck in a girl's body
um I'm gonna just be and just she's
she's 11. she's 11. 12. 11 years old
her name is Chloe at 12 years old she
told her parents she wrote them a long
letter and and the gist of it was I'm a
boy
and I want you to call me Leo
I encourage you to listen to the story
in her voice as she tells it because it
is
heartbreaking and so powerful
um if you watch it on YouTube you just
look into her eyes she's 18. now
and so but but
the the summary is
um she starts taking puberty blockers
when she's like 12 13 years old
and she was very certain about what she
wanted to do uh her parents were
naturally pretty confused and not
knowing what to do to best care for and
love their daughter
and so they went out and started looking
for health professionals to like hey
just like educate us talk talk us
through this what what are the
you know potential medical and health
ramifications of our daughter taking
these puberty blockers and and with the
exception of one endocrinologist who
told them like hey this we don't know
what the negative consequences might be
both in the short term and the long term
to this because there's just you know
it's not been studied very well there's
no long history of cases that that we
can point to to say well here's what you
can expect based on fact and Science and
so this endocrinologist is saying like
I would encourage you to think very
seriously before doing this because it
could end up badly essentially
um I forget what the name I think is a
gender specialist is what they're called
who are helping guide her through this
every other Medical Professional that
she went to see basically
urged her and encouraged her to move
forward with this
and ultimately told
her parents who were expressing some
concern and reservations
you have a choice
between having a live son or a dead
daughter
and Chloe says that up until that like
at that point she had never once had a
suicidal thought enter her mind so this
this warning and essentially this threat
that these medical professionals are
giving to this young girl's parents a
live son or a dead daughter you decide
was based on nothing
according to Chloe's medical history
fast forward she ends up getting a
double mastectomy when she's 15 years
old
to continue this transition
she talks about how they call it Top
surgery to try to you know soften what
what it really is
and was after she got that surgery that
she had a realization I think she was 16
at the time that she would know she
would never be able to breastfeed
her child ever she that had been taken
away from her because of this
this decision and you know she talks
about how she was asked at different
points along this path from when she was
12 12 through 15 like okay well here's
all these medical disclosures and you
know you might not be able to have kids
this could affect your fertility and at
12 years old she's like man I don't want
kids like how does a 12 year old girl
make that decision and then again at 15
before the surgery like okay well you
might not be able to do this or have
kids or breastfeed and you know again
children not being equipped to make
these decisions at 16 she
experienced incredible regret and
realized she'd make the biggest mistake
of her life
and then began to walk down that path of
quote unquote de-transitioning and she
talks about what that meant and
practical terms in her conversations
with her parents and friends and family
being completely shunned by this group
of you know people who are pushing this
this transgender Ideology Now now people
who celebrated her one day and the very
next day once she was like no I've made
the biggest mistake of my life
completely shunning her calling her
names giving her death threats online
doctors who had cared for her one day
the next day once she had made this
decision not returning phone calls or
telling her like you know she's still
having
um serious medical issues based on the
the mastectomy she had
that she can't figure out what to do
with and the doctor's like oh just put
some Vaseline on there
and and ultimately these doctors are not
providing her with the kind of care that
she needs or being responsive at all so
she she's actually filed a lawsuit
against these doctors and um
Kaiser
um that
she dealt with along the way which is so
brave of her to do she's so incredibly
courageous to be doing what she's doing
and speaking out and actively
encouraging others to do the same so
that people are able to be better
informed but
that that social Contagion
uh that she talks really clearly about
the algorithms having such a heavy
influence on her as a young girl
to ultimately bring her to make this
decision along with other other things
as well but
um
the the lack of
I guess I guess this phenomena in our
society right now where there's no open
conversation about this that she could
turn through that her family could turn
to to say to get a differing perspective
or differing view to where doctors feel
afraid to say anything about it I talked
to a friend of mine who's an ER doc
actually in California
and he said Tulsi I I you know would say
this off the Record but there are a lot
of kids who are coming into the ER
uh who are experiencing you know
suicidal thoughts or deep depression or
other medical issues because of this
uh transition of of people who are
similarly like Chloe Cole regretting
these decisions that they've made as
kids
and but nobody's talking about it you
know even from from the very top of of
you know where he works it was just like
all of a sudden okay hey guys we're
doing this now
and by the way it's a very
um
profitable Venture knowing that not only
the initial treatments but you're
basically once once somebody comes and
tells you they want to do this you're
talking about years of follow-on care
and drugs and all and so on and so forth
but there was no conversation about
um this at all because it's not allowed
if you even raise a question and say hey
is this really the best thing like our
kids really equipped to make this
decision when they're 11 or 12 years old
you're immediately labeled a transphobe
and how dare you not care for your kids
um in that podcast uh episode that I put
out there are actual videos from Boston
Children's Hospital as one example of
unfortunately many where they're
literally saying as soon as your child
is capable of expressing themselves
you'll see signs of them uh
you know deciding what their gender
identity is like before they can even
use words and speak any kind of language
that you look at like gestures and you
look at all these different things and
you just you see how dangerous this is
when critical thinking is like it's
discouraged asking questions is
discouraged having differing points of
view is discouraged and I think even
using the word discouraged is is putting
it lightly people get banned on social
media get their accounts
you know suspended indefinitely for
asking questions or saying hey this is
not appropriate for kids again then you
let add on the layer of government
and this is where things get so
dangerous is that you know Chloe
mentions that she knows people
personally
who parents who've had their kids taken
away from them simply because they
refuse to
call them by a name or pronoun different
than the one they were given at Birth
by Child Protective Services by the
government
and this is this is the very real
consequence of
people
just being willing to go along
and maybe it's like I I don't know this
doesn't seem right but at least it's not
happening to me or my kids or my family
so I'm just going to put my head in the
you know in the sand and not pay
attention
um but there's there's so many different
factors you start looking at it I
mentioned parents going and you know
protesting like no you know what I don't
want my seven-year-old kid being given
books to read at school about like well
tell me what your sexuality is or tell
me what your gender identity is I I
didn't you know I heard parents talk
about this stuff and I thought gosh you
know this is really concerning and then
I met with with a bunch of parents in
Virginia who've been on the
um
a group called parents defending
education have been kind of on the front
lines of this fight nationally and they
brought a stack of books and showed me
and and there was one in particular that
um it it it was a graphic novel for
middle schoolers
and I I had never seen such sexually
graphic images ever in my life
and this is something that's being given
to kids to help them you know figure out
you know what their sexuality is and
it's um
it's really disturbing that we live in a
society today
where this Open Marketplace of ideas is
not allowed to occur
and it's not allowed to occur because we
have people in power who are using the
lovers of government
working with people in the media and in
big Tech
to control
speech
and to influence
our society
foreign so when I was a kid
let's say you were gonna get crazy and
really Rebel you'd grow your hair out
right and wear a jean jacket or whatever
you know what I mean like you were
listening to Metallica and you're gonna
go through your Metallica phase and and
back then Metallica was not the same
Metallica that it is now I mean back
then Metallica was kind of Fringe
radical right and so you were going to
grow your hair out and you were making
all kinds of dumb decisions I mean let's
face it when you when you're that young
you're making just bad decisions left
and right and so thankfully your
decisions aren't permanent when when I
was a kid our decisions weren't
permanent maybe maybe you get some
tattoos that you're going to want to
wear you know a shirt or something when
you get older you're hopefully you
didn't jump straight into the neck
tattoos or again Overton window on face
tattoos and neck tattoos I mean they're
they're becoming more and more
mainstream right now but back in the day
you weren't going to be doing that kind
of thing when you were certainly not 11
12 13. and then you think about the
nor would your parents let you yeah well
there's another piece of this like
at some point saying shut up to people
became bad right when I was a kid you
tell people your parents would tell you
to shut up your teacher would tell you
to shut up you would tell your friends
to shut up when you were doing something
when you're saying something stupid
somebody's like hey shut up
and at some point that became like a bad
word
do your kids say shut up Echo Charles
not to me specifically but yeah they say
that okay but if they said it to you be
offensive
which I agree with I agree with you know
you don't want you I don't want to
expect a kid but would you tell your
kids to shut up
I can't remember but I'm not against the
word shut up at all okay I probably
don't say shut up enough
and I don't think America does right now
because sometimes you know when I was a
kid he's like I'd have some stupid idea
I might be like shut up I was like okay
you got to stop sometimes when we
realize how moldable these kids are and
gullible they are I mean this is when
when you see like the interviews or read
interviews I got a book I haven't done
on the podcast yet but it's Nazis yeah
the young Nazi kids they were 100 they
didn't know anything else they didn't
know anything else at least a lot of
them and same thing with the kamikaze
pilots that are 19 years old
they didn't know anything else and sure
there's I should I want to group them
all together because some of them
definitely were like hey wait a second
I'm not so sure about this but then they
got in those planes and drove them into
our our vessels our ships
because they were just totally
brainwashed
totally brainwashed and we
that's how moldable kids are and so when
you take a freaking 11 year old girl and
you start down this path and that's all
she's hearing and that's all the
supports you're getting because look
being a kid you know when I wrote my
when I when I wrote my first kids book
one of the things I had to put in
perspective was that you know I was
still in when I was in the military my
kids were growing up
part of my mind would be like what are
these kids talking about like nothing
matters this oh you know you know Billy
called me uh whatever called me a jerk
and I'm like so what right
I'm like hey I'm going to Iraq what are
you kidding me oh my God
I got buddies that died face down in the
mud so you could be called a jerk by
your friend is freedom of speech you
know I mean like that's how detached you
get you forget that when you're a kid
that's your whole world yeah school is
your whole world the the bully is your
whole world and and so what happens when
these kids get a world put around them
that only has one point of view and it's
pushing in more One Direction it's no
surprise at all that they end up
believing what they're hearing from
everybody and everyone's so supportive
and that the affirmation uh and the the
I mean it has and I there's no mistake
for the radical increase in numbers of
of young kids who are now saying well
you know I'm trans or I'm you know
anywhere on the spectrum of the lgbtq
stuff
um it's not like been inching like it's
like by hundreds of percent increasing
to the point where and I've talked with
teachers who say like yeah of all the
kids in my class there's maybe two who
don't consider themselves lgbtq
something and so it's kind of become
like an Abigail schreier writes about
this and in her books about how kids are
being influenced by this
um you know it's peer pressure it's
what's like are you cool are you boring
or all this other stuff I'm over here
like bring back Metallica
yeah
that seems like a lot safer of a thing
you know the other piece that you
mentioned that um is really disturbing
so
you can't ask questions about this so I
you know I obviously work with a lot of
companies talking about leadership and
one of the things I talk about when it
comes to leadership is
I should if you've got if you're working
if Tulsi if you're working for me and I
come present a plan and you ask
questions I should be totally open to
answering your questions right your your
questions hopefully are challenging to
me and they make me really think through
my idea and they pressure test my idea
and I'm happy to answer them and the
minute I say
shut up Tulsi I don't want to hear more
questions just do what I say I just lost
the argument yeah I just lost leadership
Capital because it means I couldn't
actually
articulate why we're going to do
something a certain way and it also
means that I couldn't open my mind
enough to say tulsi's got a good point I
should incorporate that into the plan or
maybe adjust my plan or maybe abandon my
plan because Tulsi has a really good
thought process about this that I didn't
think of but the minute I say you know
what just be quiet no more questions you
do what I say exactly that means I that
means there's something wrong it exposes
your weakness right so if you have a
question for me and my answer is you're
transphobic
that's not a great answer no that's not
a great answer and look could it be true
could I be a person that oh I'm scared
of transphobic people sure well let me
think through it then what am I scared
of okay let's have a conversation about
that
so but instead just to be like no I
don't want to hear any more of your
questions this is a problem and it
doesn't lead it doesn't lead to a a
situation where we make progress and
where we can actually agree upon
anything that's right
so how's the how's the leadership the
governmental leadership when you talk
about the governmental leadership
kind of helping push this type of agenda
what does that look like
well it's exactly what you're talking
about the the choice to uh ridicule
discredit smear and censor through you
know Partners in in big Tech Google
Facebook all of that rather than
actually
have a conversation based on substance
that's having this this fear you know
this uh self-censoring effect on people
where they're too afraid to even ask
questions they're too afraid to State
their own views or opinions or even
their own experiences on this
um
have you had Kristen Beck on your
podcast I have not
I think I think I I heard her talking on
Rogan uh but Kristen Beck has had
similar experiences even as a trans
adult person saying well I don't know
like this is really dangerous for kids
like these are this is a decision if
people want to make this decision as
adults this is a free country and you
have the freedom to do that and live
with whatever the outcomes of that
decision may be but for this to be
happening to kids and back has received
extremely negative consequences both on
social media and in society because of
of stating that fact
um
the government is pushing this under the
the guise of something they call gender
affirming care
which sounds like something everyone
should be for right we want to care for
and respect each other just as people
but
what they're doing is actually
abuse of kids
Chloe Cole's story is not
a rare case
there are many others
um
both documented but also those that
haven't been reported of kids who have
gone through or going through exactly
what she's been through she started an
organization to be able to reach out to
and help Provide support to other kids
who've gone through the path that she
has walked down
the the
government factor is they're saying that
if you as parents don't provide gender
affirming care than child protective
services
may come in and intervene in order to
ensure that your child receives that
care elsewhere
um they are using this gender affirming
care uh when it comes to Federal funding
so for schools for example who the
government says refuse to provide this
quote unquote gender affirming care
which may come in the form of like okay
um
not allowing
boys to go into the girls locker room
boys who say well you know I identify as
a girl if if a publicly funded School
um does not allow that to happen the
federal government says okay we are not
going to provide you with Federal
funding for what they call free and
reduced lunch for kids who are at a
certain low level in the poverty
scale
um get free and reduced lunch at schools
the government says if your school does
not provide this gender affirming Care
by allowing boys to go into the girls
locker room boys who say they're a girl
then we're going to take that money away
from you who hurts who's harmed
in that in that scenario which is
actually happening it's kids who are
hungry who can't afford to buy their own
lunch at school and so I mean there's so
many examples of this where their
hypocrisy is just playing out literally
in real time their hypocrisy of saying
well hey this year 2022 is the 50th
anniversary of the enactment of Title IX
the the law that was put in place
literally
out of a recognition of the biological
difference between the male and female
sex and to make sure that there was a
Level Playing Field because
kids like your daughter back in the day
they didn't have the opportunity to get
on a girls wrestling team because they
didn't exist in schools and with Mo with
most sports was like okay well there's
boys sports and there's girls
cheerleading that was kind of you know
or like my mom she had water ballet and
my mom's pretty athletic but her options
are pretty limited as a kid growing up
in in East Grand Rapids in Michigan
so Title IX 50 years later has created
huge opportunities for girls and women
in sports which then leads to
opportunities in different professions
and so on in their life
on this anniversary 50th anniversary of
Title IX now the government in this
Administration is is trying to or they
are actually redefining Title IX in the
law not by passing an amendment through
Congress
but instead backdoing it through a rule
change to now include this gender
identity which basically says like
anybody who says they are a woman can be
a woman
at any given point in time and therefore
by doing so
erasing
doing two things erasing women as
a group in society because now you could
if you if you wake up tomorrow you're
like yeah I'm a woman all right well the
government says now you are you are the
same protected class as a biological
woman as as me
um
but but the deeper kind of underlying
danger goes back to where we started is
this change is our government saying
there is no such thing as objective
truth there is no such thing as biology
there is no such thing as this
biological difference between a male and
female and if we as a society accept
this premise
then where are the boundaries they're
they're literally are no boundaries and
where does this lead I mean I've talked
about this before you would think that
kids are the one place where everyone in
our society can agree like we have to
kids are the most vulnerable we have to
protect our kids well now they're it has
it is starting to become acceptable to
use this term minor attracted person
which is a pedophile it's a pedophile
and yet you have teachers that's the
Overton window expanding exactly right
that's what I'm talking about and so
people are like oh yeah you know we
should just like let people be who they
want to be and kids and this and that
like okay so if you deny this shut up
comes in right you should be like hey no
shut up
yeah exactly seriously and then you have
people who are teachers
in a position to care for our kids on
social media like yeah I'm a minor
attracted person and this is how I feel
when I'm standing in front of the
classroom and using this very sexually
explicit language and and parents are
giving their children over to these
people for for more hours waking hours
of the day probably than they spend time
they're able to spend time with their
kids
and if you're you become a bigot if
you're like uh yeah no this is not okay
this normalization of pedophilia is
exactly what's happening right now how
does it happen where does it start going
back to restart like well you look at
each you know how this Overton window is
opening and and pushing you not just to
respect someone's different choices
but to openly accept and champion
these things that are literally insane
and are causing direct harm to our kids
and and again this is where
the societal shift in change this cancel
culture this this fear-mongering of
pushing self-censorship coupled with the
power of government both directly and
indirectly through big Tech is is has
put us in a very dangerous place in our
society
how much did you see with big Tech uh
collusion with the government when you
were in the government
um
quite a bit especially when I ran for
president
I um
you know and I don't know I could
probably think of a number of reasons
why it uh
it escalated so quickly there where you
know it got to a point where even as I
was you know being very outspoken on
different issues beforehand I think
certain powers that be maybe didn't
think that oh well you know she's just
saying her piece she's over here on the
sidelines but you know running for
president provides a certain platform
and
um
and it was I mean the the first kind of
eye-opening experience to me was when uh
we had the very first presidential
debate in the Democratic primaries
it was in 2019. uh you know most people
in the country didn't know who I was
never heard of me before and My Hope was
all right cool there will be millions of
people watching and I think there were
north of 20 million people who tuned
into that first debate
maybe a little off but Ballpark and
um My Hope Is I'll be able to introduce
myself let people know why I'm offering
to serve as president and
commander-in-chief and then you know
they'll go online and say okay cool I
want to learn more we set up all of our
Google AdSense accounts in the hopes
that they would do so and that I would
be able to have my
my website there uh ahead of whatever
stuff Google chose to push on people I
was the most searched candidate of the
night after that debate
which we had hoped would be the case and
uh all of a sudden our our Google ad
account was suspended with no
explanation no notice no message like
literally nothing just crickets and so
our team immediately obviously started
to reach out like hey what's going on
here we set this up according to all the
rules and da da we tested it beforehand
everything was good what happened no
response and this went on for a period
of time and then all of a sudden
we we still never got a response and all
of a sudden the account was was uh the
suspension was taken off the account and
that was the first like glaring example
directly that I felt
um what part of your mind was like oh
dang that oh that's too bad I can't
believe this weird thing happened what
part of your mind was like these
bastards these bastards
I went straight there because it was it
was were you suspect already going into
it did you or is that just like a total
eye-oper no I mean I I had you know the
the
um influence and impact of these big
tech companies in social media was
already pretty clear you know how their
algorithms were trying to push certain
kinds of information to invoke a certain
response from their from their users I
think things were becoming more and more
clear just broadly at that point
uh which is why when that happened uh it
was way too much of a coincidence to
just be a coincidence
um I I ultimately filed a lawsuit
against Google because of this to to
make the point and to make the statement
that they shouldn't be allowed to get
away with this people need to know how
much power a monopoly like Google has
on directly influencing interfering in
our elections and that that if they can
do this to a sitting member of Congress
running for the highest office in the
land
making it so that they are manipulating
and and dictating what information
people see when they type in who is
Tulsi gabbard
they can do it to anyone for any reason
uh you know whether you're running for
mayor or dog catcher or whatever it
might be
that this private Corporation
gets to determine what we as voters know
and see and hear about a person and that
that became increasingly clear
throughout my entire campaign how
um you know the the power elite as I
call them or the permanent Washington
that these are made up of some of the
most powerful people in politics the
most powerful people in corporate media
and the most powerful people in big Tech
are interfering in our elections by
dictating
who voters are exposed to and what they
are exposed to about certain people who
are are running for office they decide
what
what the narrative what the narrative is
and so to say and this is this is the
thing of course they don't talk about
when they talk about you know influence
and interference in our democracy in our
elections but it is the biggest and most
impactful thing that is influencing
voters
um and and there have been recent cases
that have come forward about Google for
example like in just in this past
election there was a report that was
done
showing that
you know political emails from
candidates going into Gmail accounts
which most people have
favored sending these uh favored
Progressive or democrat candidates or
democrat messaging to to funnel those
emails into your inbox whereas uh
conservative or republican political
emails were more than 50 percent of the
time end up in your spam box
so you know there there are a lot of
different examples of this but it's a
dangerous dangerous thing
um that is now going unchecked there's
no check and balance on that and then
you look at okay well so what are the
political leanings of these big tech
companies and Facebook has has obviously
they've been in the news a lot about
this as well
you know they they lean they have a
specific political slant but to me
whether the political slant is to the
left or to the right or if it's Democrat
versus Republican if if we don't number
one if we're not informed about it not
calling it out and not pushing our
lawmakers to say Hey you know this is
this we have to call it for what it is
they're directly trying to influence
um influence our elections we have to be
willing to do it whoever is you know
whatever their political slant is the
point is like freedom of speech is
freedom of speech
we have to be willing to protect that
freedom of speech no matter
um whether we like it or not or whether
we agree with that that speech or not I
guess the live experiments going on
right now it is with Twitter right with
you on yes and what he's doing
and he's bringing back all these people
that were banned including Donald Trump
he just brought back Donald Trump I
don't think Donald Trump has gone on and
gone back to Twitter yet and apparently
he has some kind of
commitment to the to the truth which is
another social media platform truth
media truth truth yeah
so but elon's let everybody on except
for Alex Jones
Alex Jones he did not let Arnold Echo
you're laughing at that finally got to
reaction at Echo Charles
yay nay Alex Jones yes that's funny to
me but I don't know okay he's going
through a lot of legal legal situations
right now yeah what is he he's owes
billions of dollars apparently right
billions of dollars
to the the parents of the Sandy Hook
massacre
uh but so other than Alex Jones it looks
like it looks like Elon and Twitter is
just going wide open yeah I think it's
literally other than Alex Jones what's
interesting to me about that is the
people who are publicizing that they're
leaving
because now you know as Elon said he's a
free speech absolutist can you say that
if you don't bring Alex Jones back on I
don't know can you is that is that an
absolutist technically that's not
absolute but so he's an almost
reasonably absolutely I saw the other
day that CBS News what is it they like
oh we're leaving Twitter and then I was
it like a day or two and then they came
back they came back you know Fox News
left Twitter for a long time is that
right oh yeah they left they left
Twitter for for months and months and
months they left Twitter and they stayed
off and I forget what brought them back
on but but you so you have this
experiment kind of with Elon Musk right
now opening up Twitter and I guess we'll
see what happens and I mean the whole
thing it's just such drama and that's
one thing that's interesting you know I
always feel like
all this stuff that we're talking about
is like a separate world that I'm
actually not that I don't get fully
engaged in that world because I actually
have a bunch of businesses and like
things going on and I feel like that's
more normal and if you're not careful
you think that this world that we're
talking about the world of social media
the world of Twitter the world of
Facebook the world of Instagram if
you're not careful you think that's real
yeah and you have to remember that it's
not real yeah and that it's just a it's
just a virtual world that's not real but
there's people that live and die in that
world and they and that world drives
them Crazy by the way I gotta asked that
I thought I got asked that on a on a a
podcast interview a little while ago you
know well how do you feel when people
make bad comments about you on Twitter
or on and I said hey I recommend you
don't really get concerned about those
things because it's a bot that's right
it's a bot or it's a person that's just
looking it's a troll or a bot that's
pretty much what you how many what
percentage of negative comments are
coming from a person that is making a
negative comment because their goal is
to help influence you and move you in a
better Direction and see their
perspective the chance is very true very
few it's a bot or it's a troll so why
are you getting spun up about this stuff
I was in Greensboro North Carolina a few
days ago stopped in a little shop on the
side of the road and
um this guy comes up to me
and he's like oh my God are you Tulsi
freaking gabbard he's like yeah he's
like what are you doing here there's
nothing in Greensboro it's like oh you
know I'm here for this event I'll be
speaking at later on and he's like you
know what if I was on Twitter right now
I would be putting out a tweet saying
how much I don't like Tulsi gabbard but
now you're standing right in front of me
and I can't freaking say that like
you're a real person and you know I
ended up talking to him for about five
minutes or so and he's like I gotta take
a picture I was like all right if you
posted on Twitter you better like be
true to your word here buddy and not not
start talking [__] about me but it was
just funny the interaction which is
exactly that like
in real life
very rarely I've actually had it happen
a couple of times where people will come
up and say the kinds of harsh you know
mean criticisms that they say on Twitter
maybe all the time but by and large most
people
they wouldn't have that kind of
interaction with someone in real life
what was the guy's beef with you or what
do you suspect I don't know you know it
was interesting because he was because
after he said that he's like all right
can I just ask you one question I was
like yeah like my ride's waiting outside
I don't have a lot of time but he's like
you know you you say a lot of things
that are pretty critical to democratic
party and I agree with a lot of those
things but why are you still a Democrat
I'm like oh I'm not he's like oh you're
not it's like no go listen to episode
one of my podcast and there's 29 minutes
of me telling you exactly why I left the
Democrat Party
um but then that was it then he's like
oh my gosh like okay I'm gonna go and
listen to that
um but and then he asked if he could
take a picture and then as I was walking
out there were people sitting next to me
was like that Tulsi guys like yeah
anyways it was just funny
um because I don't know that he knew
exactly what his beef was
uh but for whatever reason he was not
positively disposed towards me but then
after four minutes of a conversation uh
and just recognizing like hey yeah I'm a
real person you're a real person and
maybe we don't agree on everything
probably don't disagree on some things
cool that's fine but you know
treat each other with respect yeah and
what's scary about that is someone
that's just like I don't I don't like
you and I have beef with you and falls
on Twitter I'd be talking smack yeah and
the main reason is because that you've
been labeled as a Democrat and so
they're not a Democrat so therefore they
must hate you right and and that's the
horrible thing right because you know
someone can be anything and if you have
an open mind and listen what they have
to say oh well they got some good points
there and that really doesn't make any
sense to me right now but let's hear
what their perspective isn't and that's
a good way to
a good way to like
survive and live with other human beings
in the world yeah listen to what they
have to say maybe try and see their
perspective a little bit which it just
seems like uh is very limited especially
in the in the world of social media yeah
and this this goes to you know one of
the
uh this is something that I talked about
in my statement about why I left the
Democrat Party is how how divided our
country has become largely because of
those those you know well if you are
white therefore you are this if you are
black therefore you are that and and how
the Democratic party has completely
um gone against Dr King's dream of this
you know that his kids would one day
grow up in a society where we're judged
based on our character not the color of
our skin well now even in our our
schools elementary schools they want our
kids to be taught that if you're white
you're privileged if you are a person of
color then you are the oppressed or you
are the victim and dividing us
based on the color of our skin and
racializing everything in our society if
something happens obviously it's because
of race obviously it's because of
um the color of your skin and you you
can go down that path of these broad
categorizations whether it's based on
Party politics or race ethnicity
religion
um
any of these boxes that that they like
to put us in and use as wedges to drive
us apart rather than again Focus like
all right let's just go below the
surface and recognize that you know uh
all people from Hawaii are not the same
or
um you know what whatever the fill in
the blank is uh we we get into dangerous
territory when we judge each other just
based on You Know The Superficial or the
label that is attached to us and I've
been on the receiving end of this
constantly because I've never fit into
any one of those specific boxes and you
know friends of mine say well that that
hurts you politically because then you
don't have like that natural support
base
um but you know none of us as people are
are monoliths none of us are just
walking around as like oh you know this
these labels are attached to me
therefore I am that and it assuming that
in our society has the negative effect
of of not encouraging that critical
thinking that independent thought
um that healthy skepticism of like all
right when I read this story or I hear
this View
where are they coming from what's the
angle on it what's what's what's their
experience maybe that's informed that
that may be different from my own and
what can I learn from it you know or
what maybe I end up disagreeing with it
and but I've thought through here are
the reasons why not just because like oh
that person is in this category or this
group therefore I must disagree I must
be opposed and and that's a it has the
opposite effect of
I think the foundation of this country
which is we are all Americans out of
many there are one and this kind of
individual thought and freedom of
expression was celebrated at one time in
this country and now worse than not
being celebrated there are punitive
effects and consequences to that freedom
of expression to where it becomes
freedom of expression you know for those
in power freedom of expression is only
celebrated if they agree with it
imagine the uh being the adversary of
America like you're China right now and
you're just sitting there watching this
unfold and there's no better way to
destroy your adversary than to have them
destroy themselves and so it's no it's
no surprise when you know the the
Russian bot Farms were setting up these
these Pro these counter protests and
protests in the same neighborhoods and
and and really just doing all they could
to divide America and that's why I
always try and keep that top of mind for
myself when when I get put into a
scenario where someone's trying to
you know uh frame me up mentally yeah
frame me up mentally I'm always thinking
to myself
okay well hold on a second don't get
framed up mentally listen to what
someone else has to say see what their
perspective is and remember that they're
American and I'm an American because if
I'm an American and you're American cool
we got all kinds of things in common all
kinds of things in common I think I said
this on this podcast before unless
you're an actual Isis member yeah
we're gonna find some common ground like
we're gonna both like UFC or we're gonna
vote for like uh guitar like there's
gonna be something there yeah we're
gonna both like Led Zeppelin or whatever
there's going to be something there
where we go okay cool I'm I'm down you
know you only listen to Led Zeppelin
cool what's your favorite album like
let's go but it's really easy
to just focus on oh you like this and I
don't like that therefore you're my
enemy and we should fight which is
really really freaking lame yeah it's
really lame and that's where we get
framed up all day day long and social
media is the amplifier of that that
we've never seen before truly never seen
before I think it would clean up a lot
on Twitter if you were only allowed to
be you you're only allowed to have your
name yeah I agree with that you can't
hide behind isn't that kind of what
Facebook does Facebook does that right
can you be on Facebook and be like you
know
alpha29474 and make a bunch of comments
Echo Charles expert that's not a yes or
no question you kinda can't you could
probably get away with it right yeah
yeah
because I see people with that on
Facebook yeah yeah with a something
other than their real name yes
so maybe if you're gonna make it which
is like the catfishing right like they
put up they find like pictures of well
that depends if they're trying to
represent their identity that's true but
to take advantage of someone else yeah
you know this that's like an alias
nickname you know that kind of I see
that for sure yeah but I I don't think
Facebook is like
openly permissive about it I think it's
like they try to make you have your real
name it seems like it seems to me when I
look at Facebook comments they're people
yes yeah Twitter comments
YouTube fully not uh and the
divisiveness people this is another
thing that I find interesting is people
talk about it's never been more divisive
than it is now and I get it we want to
make headlines but man we had a literal
Civil War where 650 000 people died 650
000 people died right and even in this
late 60s early 70s there was crazy crazy
civil unrest and There Was You Know The
sivanese Liberation Army in the Black
Liberation Army and the Black Panthers
and the weather underground and these
were groups that were killing
like there was like something like 35
police officers that were assassinated
there was bombings bombings happened so
much in those days yeah that it was it
almost didn't even make the headline of
the news I mean if there's a if someone
puts a bomb off today in America that's
going to be in the front of every news
story their every news corporation there
is back in the late 60s early 70s that
stuff was just happening they were just
blowing stuff up
so it's not as bad it's not the worst
it's ever been but it certainly seems
that way when you go on social media and
you start
paying attention to that Mayhem yeah
it's true and and you know I I don't
know what the
ah the recent numbers but I I feel like
Twitter you might know this Echo but
Twitter I think is actually just became
[Music]
apparently
but it's something like
like less than five percent of Americans
are on Twitter it's some it's it's a
really it's a surprisingly low number
um but you look at uh it is known as the
place for people in politics and the
media and so when you look at uh the
outsized influence you know like a tweet
can make a news story
um
it it's not representative of you know
the vast majority of Americans in this
country but it has an outsized effect it
does have an outside effect and I think
that is safe to say it's not the it's
most people aren't spending that I had
this conversation with Ben Shapiro you
know he was talking about all this stuff
and I said hey Ben you're at Ground Zero
for like political controversy in Mayhem
and most people in America are just like
working their job going to their kids
Jiu Jitsu Tournament Wrestling
Tournament piano recital that's what
most people are doing now if you want to
open up that app and just get let it
creep into your brain
oh it's going to get in there for sure
yeah
I had to take during when I was running
for president my husband like he he
doesn't like politics and he's not a guy
he's not a social media guy at all
um but he was starting to to look at
Twitter
a lot and it got to the point where he
was like actually caught like first of
all he's like who is this person where
are they
where do they live
um but but I remember like we were
sitting like an Olive Garden for dinner
probably in New Hampshire somewhere and
he was it was he was glued to his phone
and I could like almost palpably feel
his blood pressure rising and you know
his his like Stress and Anxiety and
anger and just all of these emotions and
there's a few times I I literally had to
physically pull his phone from his hand
and then he ultimately just deleted the
app because
you know this is not a world that he
lives in I've been used to all kinds of
attacks for a really long time
um but it has
um
yeah I mean for for you can understand
that for people who don't aren't
accustomed to that sort of thing
it can have a really really negative
emotional impact oh yeah you know weird
uh one of my buddies Micah Fink who's
runs an awesome organization helping
vets but
he he said something when he was on the
podcast about like you are giving the
energy to the thing that's eating
exactly so like your husband just going
oh you know what I've had enough this
delete yeah that and one of our friends
Jack Daniel uh Jack Daniel Hill just
went on like a retreat into the
mountains
and I was like oh how was it you know
just talking to him and the first thing
he goes it was four days no phone no
watch didn't even know what time it was
and he said when he got back he said it
was such a good like dopamine reset
because you realize
what that phone does to you like how it
makes you feel you know it's like I talk
about fasting from food and one of the
best things you get from a food fast is
it recalibrates your hunger right like
you think like it's been two hours
you're an idiot right and and then you
get done with like uh fast
a three-day fast and you like I'm not
even close to hungry I'm fine and so the
dopamine hit on the phone is the same
thing like you take a break from that
thing
and you go oh this thing is running my
brain yeah it's got It's got ownership
of my brain you can't let that happen
yeah and you don't even realize it you
that that documentary social dilemma was
very eye-opening in how intentional
completely intentional like they're
looking for that exact effect oh
completely like the smallest littlest
things like opportunity for exploitation
left right and center and it's constant
and it's uh yeah I I used to wear an
Apple Watch and I don't anymore
specifically because like I don't need
that constantly constantly that's how
the weird thing is like on Twitter
obviously and and look I like Twitter
and what I like about Twitter is it's
fun because it's basically for my for my
for lack of a better word personality
you get to sit there and make one-liners
yeah it's basically just one-liners and
and it's it's easier than the one-liners
if you and I are talking because if you
and I are talking I have to do a
one-liner on the spot I have one second
think about I gotta do it yeah with
Twitter I can take seven minutes to
think of a really good one line right so
of course you're gonna win of course
you're gonna sound you're gonna sound
funny or whatever and it's a fun thing
to do but man sometimes I I'll like read
someone that's putting something on
Twitter
and you can see that they're putting
some little fraction of their of their
soul into it maybe that's a strong word
but they're putting at least some level
of effort of like hey I want to make
this point people have to hear this what
I'm about to say is going to have impact
and I'm thinking I'm sorry man but like
if you're looking to change the world
you shouldn't be trying to change the
world on Twitter you should be trying to
change the world through some other
things start a business grow a company
go out and talk to people and
communicate with them in a broad
long-term format but but to sit there
and be like all right this is the thread
this is the thread that's really going
to change things up this is the one so I
think that's a little bit sketchy and
you have to watch out for that and and
again I also think that
Twitter originally as a method of
communication when I originally got on
at Tim Ferriss he says to me oh no it's
a really good way to like talk to people
and communicate with them and you can
get a bunch of information I was like oh
I guess that sounds cool and at some
point Twitter went from a way to
communicate with a bunch of people and
have them communicate back to you and
people you don't know and it's all good
and we can all it went from that sort of
a positive communication and I still
think I feel I still feel that way about
it like I'll go on have all kinds of
positive really good interactions with
people I'm probably the only person
that's just on there
having a bunch of positive interaction
even when people say negative stuff to
me on Twitter I always say oh that's a
cool perspective thank you like well
that makes sense I never thought of it
that way and let me keep an open mind
here instead of just going on the attack
uh but yeah people gotta watch out for
that one yeah
uh so my Approach is a little different
than yours
um
I am and you know the you know social
media strategists may have have some uh
some constructive feedback here but I do
try to be pretty intentional about
things that I put out on social media
really large but Twitter limitation of
space I put I put some thought into the
statements that I'm making in the hope
that it will have an impact at least
causing people to ask a question or
maybe stop and think about whatever the
topic is that I'm commenting on
um and using it as a platform to help
inform and engage on on the issues
issues of the day it's challenging
because it's so short but uh to me all
of these different platforms yes there's
there's positives and negatives to them
so I want to try to
I I do I want to be very intentional
about what I am putting out
um
responses you know cross cross the
Spectrum but to me this is like really
the things like people are like oh you
know
uh I I always laugh at the comments that
are like oh I hate what you say or
you're so ignorant or you're terrible
all of these different things like dude
unfollow it's as simple as that or you
should not be allowed to speak
unfollow and that's that's where like
you you see how again people in
government and people in positions of
power like well we need to ban hate
speech we need to ban misinformation and
disinformation
who gets to decide what that is
you know your you know what Echo might
think is hate speech may be different
from what you might consider hate speech
what's offensive to him might be
different than what's offensive to you
you know Miss we saw this through the
covid pandemic right one day Dr fauci
says oh masks are useless don't go buy
them then the next day's like well
actually everybody really has to wear a
mask like okay so who gets to say what
is misinformation and disinformation and
what should be banned versus not banned
the the post-mortem on the covid is very
crazy to look at yeah it's a great case
study for what we're talking about last
time you were here the last time you
were here were you didn't do a podcast
but you were in town and Echo and I were
here and you just were like hey I'm in
town swing by
and so you were here Echo and I were
like Way Beyond coven I guess we were
just like not wearing masks not doing
anything you were here you were still
you were still uh in Congress you were
here you had two masks on yeah
we ended up having I ended up having to
send you the the horrible text of like
hey I'm really sorry but both Echo and I
have covered yeah after you left
but what you when you look back
what do you think of that whole gig that
whole covert thing like it was Mayhem it
was it was Mayhem and a lot of it was
caused by
um a lot of I mean look I mean fauci was
lying about masks because he didn't want
people to go buy masks because he felt
like there wasn't enough masks for
healthcare professionals and I think at
different points you know you saw how
you're not allowed to go to church not
allowed to go to a funeral not allowed
to have a wedding you're not allowed to
gather with friends in your house not
allowed to have birthday parties but
um you can go to Home Depot Walmart and
McDonald's Home Depot Walmart McDonald's
or 50 000 people in a black lives matter
March shoulder to shoulder social
distancing six feet apart like ah no and
and just the direct statements that
these so-called profession Health Care
Professionals made during that time was
like oh well you know the cause is
Worthy
so therefore it outweighs the risk of
coven but your kids are not allowed to
go to school my whole Prof my whole
perspective on this is
um individual choice and so for me like
I travel a lot I do a lot I don't want
to get sick I was wearing masks on
planes before covet happened because I I
can't afford to have days out where I
can't do what I need to do whether that
was in Congress or or now you know I
have people in my family who have
compromised immune system so generally I
am more careful than your average person
because I don't want to I don't I can't
I can't afford to get sick
but it comes down to
the the idea of individual Choice was
thrown out the window and we saw how
people in power were claiming to act in
the best interest of quote-unquote
Public Health but it really got to a
point where this was about compliance
or face the consequences it was it
became about power and that's that's the
dangerous thing as we look back at what
happened how much did how much did
government trust Decay because of covid
how much did government trust what decay
what do you mean I mean people that
maybe before covert would be like oh you
know government's saying something it's
you know government decaying trust in
the government yeah yeah yeah exactly
um I I think I think that that lack of
trust went up dramatically
um because you know oh God what was it
one of these mainstream media I don't
know if his New York Times New Yorker
one of these had an op-ed recently
published where they're just like oh
people should just forgive people like
Dr fauci for being wrong because hey
nobody really knew what was going on and
a lot of parents being like hold on a
second you know my kid was out of school
for two years and you want us to just
forgive and forget as my kids trying to
you know play catch up or or just
whatever you know again like I I've
um families who could not go and and see
a loved one in the hospital before they
died
um
there's not a whole lot of forgive and
forget I think going on by people who
really really were you know small
business owners who were forced out of
business and there's just so many
different examples
you know from a leadership perspective
you have to be honest with people about
what you know and what you don't know
and what's like your best guess and what
and look it never inspires confidence
right if we're in combat
and I say hey Tulsi
I guess you should move to that next
building right like that doesn't Inspire
the kind of confidence that people want
to hear yeah but if you and I are
working together and you know that
listen
all leadership decisions are a guess
they really are you're not making any
leadership decisions that I know 100 for
a very few let me rephrase that very few
leadership decisions that you make as a
human being in leadership position you
know 100 what's gonna happen and if you
did then who cares right if I know 100
oh I know 100 if we make this investment
we will 100 that's not even a decision
right that's just a smart move that
you're gonna make yeah if I knew on the
battlefield 100 if you take down this
building we're gonna get the flank on
the enemy and not lose anybody right
great that's that's not that's just a
move right right
but when it comes to making decisions
you gotta you gotta recognize number one
that hey this is a guess that I'm making
right now based on the information that
I have and when more information comes
out I'm probably gonna have to make
adjustments to what I said 15 minutes
ago 15 days ago 15 weeks ago or whatever
and and yet it seemed like people's egos
were so fragile exactly that they just
dug in and just yeah the one that made
no sense it made no sense anymore even
when it made after they had the freaking
Super Bowl in Los Angeles with how many
people were there Echo Charles I don't
know 80 000 or something like this and
they're they're all in there and then in
La at that time
I had gone to La for something it was
full on
like everyone's wearing a mask and then
they had the Super Bowl and no one's
wearing a mask and then they go back and
it's like it didn't make sense yeah and
no one said hey you know what what we
thought a month ago two months ago
whatever
we've we've we've adjusted what we're
thinking because we we might have been
wrong about that and and here's what
we're thinking now this is our best
guess this is how we're going to move
forward none of the happiness freaking
ridiculous and the crazy thing is like
you know as uh someone who has you know
especially in the military but in
politics been exposed to good leaders
and and you know bad leaders
what I would hope for for from uh
someone in a leadership position is just
that honesty and transparency say hey
here's the decision that we made based
on the information that we had we have
new information and so here is here's
the guidance or here's here's the
direction uh that we're headed like that
would engender more trust and more
respect by the to those in in positions
of power and and uh and Leadership
rather than exactly what you're saying
we we saw where
they were more concerned about not
admitting like hey we got that one a
little wrong we're gonna adjust and kind
of course correct they're more concerned
about that than they were about actually
doing what was right and what was best
and not concerned for the consequences
more concern for themselves and how
people might perceive them yeah and
that's almost reality everybody knows
everybody knows I asked hundreds of
people this question when I talk about
leadership like if I go to you and I say
hey Tulsi I'm not really sure how to
conduct this Mission what do you think
we should do yeah everybody knows that
that's a better attitude
and better leadership than if I'm not
really sure how to conduct an operation
I say all right Tulsi here's how we're
doing it and this is what we're gonna do
because I said so everybody knows that
the first leader that asks for input and
has an open mind everybody knows that
leader is more respected everybody knows
that and yet when we're in the
leadership position we decide to think
you know what everyone's going to think
I'm I don't know what I'm doing if I ask
Tulsi what her opinion is it's freaking
totally ridiculous and it's totally
wrong and yet it's our ego our ego is so
strong that it overpowers our actual
knowledge of what good leadership is we
all know the better leader says hey you
know I'm never conducting operation like
this before Tulsi I know you have how do
you think we should do it everybody
knows that that's better leadership than
tulsi's got a bunch of experience in
this type of operation I've never done
it before but I don't want to look bad
so I'm going to dictate how we're doing
it everybody knows that that's bad yeah
and yet our ego pushes us to do that
it's ridiculous That's How Strong the
ego is one of my favorite series of all
times is Band of Brothers and it was
something that um I first learned about
as an e i just gotten into the Army
National Guard we did our annual
training at Fort Indiantown Gap in
Pennsylvania and I had happened to pick
up the book Band of Brothers by dick
Winters
um as we were out there was reading it
was on the plane going back to Hawaii
when I finished it in the very back of
the book it says you know dick Winters
has now retired and is residing in Fort
Indiantown Gap Pennsylvania I was like
oh my God I would have loved to go knock
on that guy's door
that would have been incredible but I've
watched that Series so many times in OCS
we actually had we watched episode by
episode we had to write essays on each
episode talking about Leadership Lessons
and for those who've seen it
um the captain Sobel character who was
Ross from Friends he is that guy he is
that guy who was totally driven by ego
did not care about what was right or
drawing from experience or anything else
he was right to a fault and his soldiers
suffered and they lacked any respect for
him like blatantly saluted the rank
solely but that was it like following
him into combat terrified them and they
talked about this and raised this
through their chain of command versus
dick winners the guy who really
represented and embodied those those the
the
the characteristics of servant
leadership and humility and you know
drawing on the strengths of his ncos and
his men
um to be able to make sure that they
were taking care of each other and
accomplishing the mission yeah at
Echelon front we do that we we actually
take chunks of Band of Brothers and talk
about it and again everybody knows that
Captain Sobel is hated yep and everybody
knows that when you come when you try
and demand respect from people it
doesn't work everyone knows that and yet
people freaking do it actually on front
my leadership company wouldn't exist if
this stuff if people could just
just kind of exciting on what they know
yeah but that ego is so strong that it
just overpowers the ability to listen to
what other people have to say it
overpowers the people the ability to
allow themselves to be influenced by
what other people are saying they think
of that as weakness if you say hey
janako I think we should attack this
target from the north instead of from
the West
and in my mind I think wait a second I'm
gonna look weak if I accept tulsi's
input right now I'm so no right our ego
just drives us and this is again I think
this is one of the major issues that we
see in America
is that a lot of times people think I'm
gonna look weak if I do this I'm going
to look bad or I don't want to submit
I don't want to subordinate my ego I
don't want I don't want Tulsi to be the
one that had the good idea so I'm not
going to use her idea I'd rather just
fail isn't it crazy it it happens in
business a lot where I I come up with
the idea my idea is not working but it
was my idea so I'm just gonna lose I'm
gonna I'm gonna go bankrupt
and people think no no one would do that
oh yes they will and they do and and the
extreme example is combat there's plenty
of historical examples where people have
gotten their troops killed and in some
cases gotten themselves killed because
they just didn't want to they didn't
want to say you know what I was wrong
about this we shouldn't attack we
shouldn't do a frontal assault right now
we should actually take a step back
maybe Retreat a little bit and come and
attack a different day there's plenty of
examples in history where people die
because their ego gets in the way so it
happens in business and if it can happen
in in business and people can bankrupt
the company it can happen in battle and
people can get people killed it will
certainly happen all day on Twitter
where people say I would rather just
perish yeah than than admit that oh
that's a good point I didn't think
through that
and obviously it happens in politics
every single day oh yeah and I think the
interesting thing about that is these
are decisions that are made out of fear
their motivation is fear ultimately is
themselves looking stupid or silly or
not getting the credit or whatever it is
and I I could examples day and night I
could tell you in politics how people
who are elected into these positions of
leadership
are really followers who are looking to
react to certain situations what will
put me in the best light you know how
can I take advantage of this to further
myself or
make those decisions based on fear fear
of like hey I don't want to stand out
from the crowd I don't want to get this
criticism I don't want to be ostracized
by this group or that group or what if
these people don't like me or what if
you know I don't get the credit for this
and and that was you know one of the
first
um days that I had as a new member of
Congress in Washington uh you know the
message from democratic party leadership
was like hey you you need to make sure
that that we as a party get the credit
for what you're doing so if there's a
bill with a good idea that one of your
Republican colleagues puts forward and
they want you to join them on it don't
do it because you'll make them look good
just take their idea and you introduce
the bill so that you and therefore the
Democrats get credit for it and then and
only then will we advance that idea
because if it's the other guys that now
you know we'll just let that bill die
silently uh in the night and and you
know if if this were just you know
um
I don't know running for class president
in high school that'd be one thing but
then you take this example and you look
at people who are making decisions based
on our foreign policy and where and when
our men and women are sent into combat
and not being willing to say hey uh we
got that one wrong or hey we need to
re-look at how we're thinking about this
problem set and ask the question how
does this best serve the interests of
the United States our national security
the interest of the American people
instead of like I gotta look tough I
gotta be strong I gotta pound my chest
and the the unfortunate and this is why
I talk a lot about how the most
important responsibility the president
has is to serve as commander-in-chief
and the danger of having a weak minded
person
in that position who does not understand
the seriousness of that job is they feel
they have to prove their strength and
what better way to prove that strength
than to say hey I'm gonna go drop some
bombs I'm gonna go send in you know our
our meanest baddest fighters to go into
a certain situation or start a war
insert ourselves into a conflict without
actually saying hey maybe
exercising restraint in the situation is
actually the not only the right move but
it's the the power move it's the move
that actually serves the interest of our
country and that's that's the dangerous
consequence of exactly what you're
talking about of ego and and leaders
making decisions based on emotion and
fear rather than actual assessment of
all right what are we looking at what
are the consequences of course of action
a b c and d and what exactly are we
trying to accomplish
freaking depressing is there anywhere
is there any freaking light at the end
of the tunnel for our our government yes
what is it
us
the light the light at the end of the
tunnel is people who are
frustrated
by the status quo people who are
concerned for what kind of future that
we want to leave behind for our kids
what kind of country we want them to
grow up in
be
when I say Be the Change it's it's
recognize the vision that our Founders
had for this country that
you know literally escaping
control and being governed by a monarchy
where the people had no say to forming
this country based on the foundation of
a self-governed people
and what what does that actually mean
what does that look like it's We the
People fulfilling our responsibility in
selecting leaders who truly are a
government of the People by the people
and for the people there's a lot of
different ways that any one of us can
get involved and and be a part of that
but the basic the bare minimum is
cast your vote and do a little bit of
work just a little bit to make sure that
the votes that you're casting are based
on you know
informed you know
figure out figure out what what you what
you want and this is not to say and you
know you'll hear in politics like oh
one side only wants to get their side
out to vote in hopes everybody else
stays home
the more we have this Open Marketplace
of ideas the more we exercise our rights
and freedoms and make sure that our
voices are heard then we have the kind
of robust democracy that that our
Founders envisioned
again back to the depressing Viewpoint
over from Draco is uh the game
that gets played as far as the whole
political system the game that's getting
played is not
conducive to people hey okay this is
what I'm thinking right now and this is
what my beliefs are and I'm gonna go out
and vote and therefore if a bunch of
people are thinking like me then we'll
probably do okay
the game that's being played is like
it's all about how much money can you
can you put into advertising and how
much how many people can you get to vote
and what methodology is there for voting
I mean some of the voting things are
crazy some of the things that happen
with with voting and the way voting
takes place
so it seems like the game
that the politicians are playing
there's you know that the people are
just sort of Pawns that are yep here's
what we're going to do to get the pawns
to vote this way and here's what the
we'll get the we'll get the result that
we want
all of that is absolutely true
and and knowing that that is true and
knowing that that's the case is so
important for us to know as voters what
we're being subjected to and why and is
exactly to try to manipulate us to vote
in the way that one side or the other
wants us to
and knowing that then we can take a step
back and again encourage that critical
thinking encourage that as you're
getting information whether it's on a
television ad or a social media post or
news article
um
exercise your own discernment and pause
for a minute think about okay well what
what is their bias what are they what do
they want me to think or how do they
want me to react to this
there are there are some apps out there
I know there's there's a bunch there's
one that I have on my phone called all
sides and it's an app that will present
kind of the news headlines of the day
and it'll say well this new source is
left-leaning this one is neutral this
one is right leaning and it's not
foolproof by any means but there there
are some quick ways to kind of look out
there and get a little bit of an idea of
what direction or angle or bias is
certain media source is taken so that
you know okay well if I read this then
okay well that's that's kind of the
outcome they want me to have but being
aware of that I think is is the first
step there are a lot of other policy
changes that that I think need to take
place to address some of the problems
that we're talking about but uh that can
only happen when we throw out
leaders who are abusing their power and
actually start to get real leaders into
office who who will take us in in the
right direction
when you say policy changes to address
some of the things that have happened
like what do you mean I mean the big
Tech I think is is a is a huge one that
as long as politicians are in the
pockets and getting money from the
Googles and metas of the world
um we're not going to see those kinds of
changes take place we hear I've heard a
lot from both Democrats and Republicans
about oh you know big Tech monopolies
are such a big problem it's like yeah
okay so what are you doing about it and
when you look at it like they're not
they're not doing anything about it
actually there's a you know a healthy
debate and conversation that needs to be
had about how do you
you know what what role does government
play in in regulating these these
monopolies I think first you know there
there's
section 230
um within the U.S code provides big Tech
essentially with the legal immunity that
a publisher like the New York Times does
not have
because originally they thought okay
well big Tech you know like they they're
not going to be to be an Arbiter and a
curator of information they're just
going to be you know an awesome platform
whereas the New York Times does curate
you know what letters to the editor they
choose to publish or the Articles they
choose to publish
um but in reality in an application
these big Tech monopolies are are
exactly they're curating very very
carefully every single thing that we see
and yet they are not being held legally
liable in the same way that a a
publisher would so that's that's kind of
basic um number one of like okay how
should they be treated some say oh they
should be treated as a utility
much like the phone company where you
know the phone company doesn't control
who calls who or the content of any
conversation they are just a platform
for us to be able to communicate and
talk to each other so I think I think
this
um
big Tech obviously does not want to lose
that legal immunity uh if they are a
free speech platform then be a free
speech platform if they're a platform
that says well we're only going to push
these certain viewpoints then people
know that and we'll know that going in
um
that's that's a that's an important
place to start to make it so that these
monopolies
I I have been a big fan of of breaking
up uh big Tech
um
using existing Provisions within the law
that my standard antitrust types exactly
uh to to avoid exactly what we're seeing
now or you can say oh well you know you
can use DuckDuckGo instead of Google
but you're not going to get the same
kind of effect and reach of being able
to get as much information as you you
would because Google has a monopoly
um and they're different approaches to
this but recognizing the problem and how
they're directly interfering in
our elections uh as one major example we
talked about Chloe Cole there are other
situations that like the Biden the
hunter Biden exactly that's a great
example is that not crazy
it's insane it's insane how how you know
for for people who don't know it was
like just weeks before the general
election in 2020 hugely consequential
election you have this discovery of a
laptop that Hunter Biden left at a
computer store
and then you have I think it was at 50
or 51
uh either current or retired senior
intelligence officials like people who
headed the CIA coming out with a blanket
statement saying that the contents of
this laptop should not be released
because it could be disinformation from
Russia trying to influence the outcome
of our election
and then
uh I don't know is it the FBI who told
Facebook not to I told Facebook to
expect Russian propaganda in the in the
near future right and then that kind of
got put in with it and Mark Zuckerberg
on Rogan's podcast said he he said he
didn't do what Twitter did was Twitter
just would just deleted any of those
tweets that were pointing people in that
direction Facebook just downplayed it or
de-escalated its its growth so no one
really saw it right which which is
essentially the same thing yeah and
that's like you can't that seems totally
insane that that happened well you think
about why why why did they do this
it was because they were concerned oh
yeah that the information on the laptop
would cause people to not vote for Joe
Biden and instead vote for Donald Trump
not a single one of those uh there I
forget what news it was but they went
back
um once the obviously the election was
over and and the the information on the
laptop had been released had gone back
to any of those senior intelligence or
all of them actually they reached out to
all of them to say hey now that you know
what you know
do you regret making the statement that
you made blaming Russia on this uh and
many of them didn't respond to the
question those that did not a single one
of them said I regret it or I was wrong
not a single one of them most of them
saying well I stand by my statement
this is this is such an egregious I mean
that this has to this has to be called
out for for what it is this is people in
in major positions of power and
influence essentially stealing our
democracy stealing our right as vote
voters
to have all the information available to
us before making this hugely
consequential consequential decision on
who our President should be but yet this
is the problem right this is the game
that you're talking about this is the
problem is like no one's holding these
people to account no one's holding their
feet to the fire no one's demanding like
hey
you know you you have completely
discredited yourself if you're not
willing to say hey I was wrong
yeah that's like one of the solilinsky
again one of the rules and he's got a
whole section that's not just one of his
rules he's got a whole section on the
rules of the means to an end and it's
basically if you're gonna you do
whatever it takes you do whatever it
takes to get to what you want and that's
why people you know in that in that
situation they go no I don't I don't I
don't regret my statement because it's a
means to an end and they got what they
wanted which was to get a bunch of
people not to see information that may
affect the way that they vote
and that is such a dangerous dangerous
mindset
dangerous mindset where again it's it's
so short-sighted because you know that
that's true and I've talked to people
personally who have said like you know
there's they they will do anything and
everything to protect to prevent Donald
Trump from getting elected president
and he's not he is he is he's very hated
by by a bunch of people hate it is like
lightly used there's a level of hatred
that's just it's blinding it's blinding
right it's blinding and that's how
short-sighted that mentality is so you
know means to an end use whatever means
available and necessary to prevent that
specific outcome
turn the tables around
what about when you're on the other end
of that stick and you have the opposing
side saying hey now it's your side that
we believe is the most dangerous thing
for America
we're willing to do whatever it takes to
stop you or whoever you're advocating or
whatever whatever the case may be that
is such a dangerous
mentality to have
and there are examples throughout
history of
authoritarian dictators who themselves
believe like I am the righteous one I am
the savior
and I'm willing to do whatever it takes
because only I know what's best
for the people
are you tracking the FTX meltdown at all
marginally I've read I've read kind of
the top lines on it but yeah but I look
it's I don't even know what today is I
think it's the 22nd of November but and
so this this case is unwinding as we
speak but right now it looks bad yeah
because these people were they set up a
big Ponzi scheme for all practical
purposes and with money from that Ponzi
scheme the they they were the number two
donor to the Democratic party right
second only to George Soros
so and and this guy the the guy that was
running it Sam whatever
he's he's he's this big donor and then
they were setting him up he was the one
that was going to advise the government
on how they should structure regulatory
environment around digital currency I
mean this is this is gonna get ugly but
that's the kind of situation where
you're you know on the outside you if
you're a normal person in America and
you're working on your farm or you're
working in your factory or you're doing
construction or whatever it is you're
doing
you're you're not thinking that there's
just straight Dr Evil [__] going on yeah
where this dude's paying to have all
these people elected I mean you don't
think that a hundred million dollars has
an impact on on the way an election
turns out I mean that's
having a huge impact a huge impact and
so here's this guy and now he's getting
uh oh yeah you donated money so we're
gonna let you set up the regulations
around cryptocurrency which is the
business that you're in which is what
and again I'm not following the case too
close and it's really early and not a
lot of it's come out but one of the
other crypto dudes CZ
some guy named CZ he was like oh you're
he uh Sam was trying to set the gig up
for himself of course it wasn't out of
like this altruism of like blockchain
technology and cryptocurrency and you
know all of you know for people who are
big Advocates of that and the
opportunity they see for that in the
world of technology that was not his it
did not appear to be his motivation yeah
and this dude CZ was like oh I see what
you're trying to do and he is the one
that kind of caused this whole thing to
fall apart which now of course you think
well thankfully it fell apart when it
did because it was a big house of cards
anyways yeah but as you look at this
like I said as a normal human that lives
in America and you you don't think that
there's Dr Evil [__] going down where
people are buying elections you're
thinking that things are like hey this
is America
and the fact of the matter is there is
this kind of thing going on there is
this massive amount of influence the big
Tech really is doing this kind of thing
the the politicians really are bought
and by the way that company gave money
to Republicans as well they were hedging
their bets they should have hedged their
bets better with their freaking Bitcoin
by the way because it ended up causing
but they had their bets Republican and
Democrat more much more to the Democrats
probably because they thought oh well
Democrats are going to be in power so we
better support them right now yeah and
and so I think that's what's really
disturbing this game is being played the
surface of it you know we all think it's
on the up and up and as soon as you look
below the surface it's dirty yeah and
it's corrupt and it's disgusting yeah
that pay to play I mean it's a perfect
example of the whole pay to play
mentality that that is so relevant in
Washington I think last time we I was on
your show we talked a little bit about
big Pharma same thing you look at how is
it possible that that still big Pharma
has so much power and so much influence
in Washington they get sweet deals so
that they can make more profits even
when you're looking at government
purchases of government of Health Care
buying buying prescription drugs
they're I think since most people in
society recognize that this kind of
outsized influence is wrong and it's
counter to the the public interest and
yet many members of Congress are bought
off by big Pharma and they won't take
those votes they won't take those votes
that hurt the people who give them their
campaign donations and give them their
campaign checks
big Pharma spends more money on
political contributions and lobbying
than they do on those crazy television
ads that we see all the time of like you
know the the happy family frolicking in
the meadow promoting whatever the drug
may be side effects might be suicidal
ideations massive diarrhea and right and
I don't think you can turn on I don't
think you can watch like one commercial
like segment without seeing at least one
prescription drug add and you think
about the fact that how like TV ads are
expensive very expensive and then you
think about well gosh they're spending
multiple times that amount to influence
to buy influence in our government to
protect themselves how does a politician
put money in their own pocket from a big
Pharma
uh I think there there's a spectrum
there
um you know those who are actually
following all the laws make it so that
uh those kinds of contributions make it
so that they are getting the vast
majority of the money in their political
Campaign which gives them security
against any potential Challenger
uh are coming from these big
corporations and lobbyists rather than
from voters so that's kind of the first
thing if you look at like hey if you're
following the letter of the law even
then
you're protecting your own self-interest
rather than what's the interest of the
people in your constituency who are
actually the ones who are hiring you
uh you look at the most one of the most
egregious examples is where politicians
will take money in their campaign and
either live in the gray space of like oh
well you know and there are examples of
this like I'm going to use campaign
money to pay for my spouse's salary
because my spouse is helping out on the
campaign or I'm gonna use you know a
hundred thousand dollars to pay for
child care because by paying for child
care then I can go out and work on my
campaign
um there there was somebody that I
worked with in Congress who
used I mean he he actually got convicted
uh because he was breaking the law but
used all hundreds of thousands of
dollars to pay his rent to pay for uh
dental bills for his family to pay for
all kinds of personal uh expenses and
and you know still to this day he's just
like ah this is a Witch Hunt this is you
know they're coming after me because
they don't like what I'm saying like no
dude you broke the law you know but
there's there's a whole Spectrum there I
think all of which end up in a place
where you know these are self-serving
interests rather than actually being
accountable to to your voters
how do you uh because I get asked this
how do you square up the
distrust of the government with I'm
going to serve in the armed forces
the question I get asked a lot yeah and
and I answer it but how how do you
answer that you're you're not active
duty but you're a current reservist yeah
you go on active duty on a pretty
regular basis and yet you know the you
know what how the sausage is made in
Washington DC
how do you square those two opposing
things that are going on
I'm proud to wear the uniform of this
country and the American flag I'm proud
to do my part in upholding that oath
that we take when we enlist in the
service
I'm honored to serve with great
Americans who share that same Mission
and those ideals
I have because I'm in the reserves and
not active duty I'm in the unique
position of also being able to try to
effect change in the political sense
recognizing we have a civilian-led
military
uh in trying to lead our country in
the right direction
to where we are honoring that Vision
that our Founders had for us that we're
honoring the service and sacrifice being
made by our brothers and sisters in
uniform and their families and that we
are making the best decisions that serve
our own National Security interests and
the freedom and prosperity of of the
American people
um
when we have people in politics who are
so compromised by the
military-industrial complex or one
interest or another that is not the
interests of the country and the
American people
obviously those in military in the
military are the ones who suffer the
consequences when they make self-serving
decisions
um even as somebody who served in Iraq
like you
whether we agree or disagree with those
decisions that are made by those
civilians in leadership it does not
undermine the promise that we make to
each other uh and to the Constitution as
we continue to fulfill that
to fulfill that promise
yeah obviously for me uh besides the
the just freaking awesome job that it is
being in the military which I loved
being in the military but when you're in
the military you can you have an
opportunity to sort of
mitigate the bad decisions that get made
and you also get the opportunity to
shape the military itself so when you're
in the military you can do a much better
job of of taking people and like getting
people the right mindset that's going to
be beneficial for the country and for
whatever country we're going into yeah
as opposed to if you're not in the
military and you're sitting on the
outside saying well it should be like
this well if you're in the military you
can actually make some of those things
happen exactly and you can do it within
the within the guidelines that are set
forth by the military but you can do it
in a positive way so I guess that's how
I always tried to square it but it's so
true it's so true and right now
um I I'm grateful to I often have the
opportunity to go and provide in the
army they call it LPD it's like
leadership professional development
sessions with either soldiers who are
going through training pipelines or
those who are out in the force for
exactly that purpose to to
have hopefully have an impact in helping
make sure that we have Discerning
leaders in the military not just robots
who you know aren't actually thinking
through the kind of responsibility that
they have regardless of their rank as
they're carrying out their task and
their mission the other cool thing for
you is you being able to explain to
leaders in the military hey this is what
it looks like from the governmental side
you should probably go brief every
military uniform with what's going on
with that because I mean even when I was
in I would kind of get try and grasp
that and try and explain to people hey
this is what it looks like from a
political political perspective but for
you that's that's you have the real
experience to say hey this is why we're
getting asked to do this this is what it
looks like here's what it took to get
this decision made here's why we need to
execute it here's what happens if we
don't so that's that's pretty bad it is
it is and and you know I've I've had the
opportunity to work a lot within the
Special Operations Community
particularly because they they are
looking for this kind of insight uh and
one thing I've really appreciated
especially in the Special Operations
Community versus the conventional
military what's not where it's not
really encouraged so much but really
that problem-solving mindset
um a little bit of that challenging
mindset uh where
you know being a robot is discouraged
you are actually encouraged and
incentivized to be somebody who's like
hey how can we do this better or why is
this actually the best way or how was
this decision made whether you're an NCO
or an officer and I just having that
encouraging that critical thinking and
recognizing again the impact that you
have on people is is so important and I
wish it was something that was more
encouraged across the military as a
whole what are you right now a
lieutenant colonel yeah
when do you up for Colonel full bird
colonel I think the window opens maybe
in about a year or two
um
yeah I'm not exactly sure but uh we'll
see the the results of the command board
are supposed to come out any day now and
if I have if I have uh I'll find out if
I have the the privilege of being
selected to be a battalion Commander for
a civil Affairs reserves battalion what
are your chances like how hard is it to
get selected for that
um it all depends on in the reserves
it's a little bit different than the
active duty where
um obviously you've got to be able to
balance your time with whatever your
civilian job or profession might be with
with
um
the responsibilities of being a
battalion Commander
um so it kind of depends on how many
people are opting in or out on any given
year
but there's a lot more it is competitive
it is competitive if you get picked up
as a reservist battalion Commander do
you how much time do you have to spend
like active as a battalion Commander do
you have to do more on paper you have
the same minimum requirement of you know
the the one weekend a month two weeks a
year but a friend of mine uh was
selected last year he's a little bit
ahead of me
um and there's there's a lot of love
time as we say there's a lot of love
time because in a reserve unit you rely
a lot on your full-time staff the
full-time reservists who are running the
staff shops you know the Personnel shop
the operation shop
and uh he's gonna give me his best
practices because he's just like yeah
he's he runs his own business it's kind
of uh and his business is doing very
well uh he has different projects around
the world and and he's also a reserve
Battalion commander and he's just like
yeah it's a lot it's a lot but it's it's
freaking awesome yeah yeah
and so
other than that yeah how what else you
got going on right now
um
what else are we doing I got the Tulsi
gabbard which you finally launched I
know it took forever you came and talked
to Echo and I about I think that's why
you stopped by you came right you came
by to like uh suck our brains on what
you know how to do a podcast yeah and
Echo decided to give you all of his
advice yeah yeah I took notes
um we took we took uh we took all of the
advice uh after that I ended up getting
deployed to East Africa and was gone for
a while and then came back and just you
know a lot of things happened uh but
yeah finally finally pushed it out
and it's just you know I mean it's it's
such a great opportunity and platform to
be able to to dive into you know
different issues different topics have
have great conversations
um and so you know or people like you
know like the guy in in the you know the
coffee shop in Greensboro he's like oh
my God why don't you leave a different
kind of oh okay go listen this episode
one will tell you exactly the answer to
what you're looking for how often are
you doing the podcast to come out once a
week uh once a week every Tuesday push
out a new episode every Tuesday
and where are you recording them
wherever I uh for the most part
recording at home in Hawaii
we got rid of a living room we lived in
a tiny two-bedroom place and uh decided
that having a studio was more practical
than having a living room hell yeah
literally we were like if we're just
sitting around the couch or not we're
not using our time very well so we got
rid of the couch and um my husband's a
cinematographer so we put together a
studio and so I'm sure they will be on
the road once at different points but uh
so far
doing them from home and then do you
have a sub stack did I see that yeah so
let's just recognize like my whole
approach is there's so many different
platforms that people get information
from and some people like to listen to
podcasts other people don't like
podcasts and they they would rather
watch cable news and other people don't
like any of that and would rather read
and so for each of the episodes at a
minimum for each of the the podcasts
that I'm putting out that I'm talking
about a different issue
I jot down my notes and put them out on
sub stack for people who just want to
get a little bit of a summary
of where I stand on certain things or my
thoughts or views on on uh something
that might be happening in the news or
something like that
and then YouTube you're on YouTube We're
on YouTube on Rumble and and you're oh
yeah no oh you're on Rubble Rumble Echo
Charles what's up oh I think we're on
rumbly wait you think we're on wrong
because I know I talked to you about
getting us on Rumble yeah uh I think
it's a matter of how many episodes are
in around okay so we're kind of on
Rumble let me double check that [__] it
back okay I appreciate it let's Circle
back he'll say yeah
and uh then you're doing some spots on
Fox News you sat in for taco Tucker
Carlson the other night yeah
um second time uh yeah he or his team
asked for me to uh to guest host for him
when he was off
and that man that's a new experience
I've never done that before anywhere
else and
um hosting an hour
44 minutes soon you count in you know
commercials of live television is
definitely a new experience a different
level of like
there ain't no room for mistakes it's a
thing it's a thing that it's a thing
that people have some people are good at
it like when you when you go and you see
what the what the news what are they
called newscasters broadcasters what are
they called hosts what are they called
yeah
he would be a host because you know he's
more on the opinion side of things than
like your your Brett Bear on Fox is a
little bit more of like a news kind of
more of a straight news guy when you see
what that job I would not like that job
yeah do you like it I had a lot more fun
than I expected to have to be honest I
it was it was certainly a lot of because
you know
his show's on every night and obviously
Tucker's been doing this forever and
he's you know good at it I'd say I mean
he has he has the top rated show on Fox
News
and so
um you know for me going in I sometimes
they have guest hosts who literally just
show up and then they get given the
whatever's going to be on the
teleprompter
um I'm not I I don't I wouldn't do that
for anybody
um if I'm reading words on a
teleprompter they're going to be words
that I wrote and so working with his
team to write and structure the show you
know all within the span of like a six
hour time frame
it's a lot it's a lot and uh but it's
look I mean it I I actually did end up
having having fun just just taking
advantage of the opportunity to be able
to
share my own views on what's Happening
and and have conversations with people
it is challenging and like okay you get
four minutes to talk to somebody and you
got somebody in your ear like literally
like I asked the first question the
producer's like okay you have 90 seconds
like okay rap rap and I'm like oh my God
like I would love to either challenge
what they're saying or ask another
follow-up or whatever and it is the
weirdest me and my buddy Lai from who I
wrote books with and hit when his wife
worked at Fox News and Jenna Lee and so
I would when I would go to New York you
know a lot of times I would just stay
with them and so I would kind of see her
schedule and life and I was like oh my
God yeah it's grueling it's grueling I
didn't want anything to do with that so
even the one hour session one now I
guess you're gonna get good out a person
would get better at it you know and you
could see that Jenna she was totally
comfortable with it I mean it's just the
way it is it's just like anything yeah
anything else you need to get used to it
but that's a yeah uh you know have you
ever been on Maria's show Maria Bartolo
I have yeah that that I was so impressed
with that woman when I've gone on her
show gone our show a number of times and
she's just she's got to be so smart yeah
I would sit there and go because you
know you're watching her beforehand
you're watching her in between because
like you said in between they're like
hey we got this and here's these numbers
and then like boom the camera goes back
on the red light comes on and she's all
just squared away with everything she
sent yeah it's pretty it's a different
kind of human you can tell there's a
skill I guess there's a certain you know
like Michael Jordan's gonna be good at
basketball there's a certain type of
human being that's going to be good at
that job yeah you've got to be
I mean obviously you've got to be very
focused and you've got to be able to
discern kind of the of all of the the
activity and voice in your ears and
everything else that's going around you
got to be able to separate kind of the
noise from
the task at hand and not allow yourself
to be
um shaken or distracted by whatever is
going on around you and that's that's
part of it so are you going to do it
more
uh we'll see they say they uh they've
been pretty happy with it and and so
they're saying like Okay well we look
forward to having you do it more often
we used to catch a lot of crap for uh
going on Fox News
like it was
I even I have because I've go I'll go on
Fox News I still go on Fox News you know
how many times CNN has asked me to be on
CNN
zero zero yeah
zero yeah uh same thing with any other
Fox News ask MSNBC yeah msnb they they
don't ask me to come on and talk to them
yeah that's but you I mean I guess it's
the same thing yeah it's the same thing
you know it it towards the end of my
well first of all like throughout the
entire time that I was in Congress you
know I I was asked on all all three of
the different networks
um over the years the invitations have
shifted and changed based on whatever I
was advocating for if like CNN wasn't
really going after it then like oh I
wonder why I don't hear from this show
or that that literally happened to you
literally when you first noticeably when
you first showed up as a congresswoman
and you were kind of like a little bit
of a kind of a rising star right so they
say so you were a rising star well you
just were they calling you all the time
all the time and I just like I I was
just you know over over the years people
are like oh you know who's your
publicist who's doing all this I was
like my phone's just ringing I don't
have a publicist I have somebody who
used to be like a Communications intern
who's answering the phone calls but it
was very very unexpected and I was just
like okay like I'll take advantage like
if it makes sense then I'll take
advantage of this platform to be able to
say what I want to say but
um it was a palpable shift over the
years as you know I would I would speak
out on a certain issue or
um
you know I didn't support Hillary
Clinton in 2016 and that was like oh
okay well it was literally considered
blasphemy and politics and then again in
in 2020 when I ran for president
um
it was you know I I saw this shift uh
just throughout that campaign where
there was already a negative bias
towards me from the day that I announced
my candidacy uh because I had a track
record of being somebody who called it
straight and was very outspoken against
the foreign policy establishment in
Washington and their decisions and uh
that that progressed throughout the
campaign where it got to a point where
um instead of even covering me or
instead of mentioning hey this person is
the candidate for president they just
stopped including my name and articles
about Democrats running for president
completely as though I didn't exist it
was a media blackout at a certain point
throughout the time
Fox News consistently has been a
platform where I've been invited on
consistently did they invite you to talk
about issues that you were in
disagreement with them yeah over the
years and they didn't care and one thing
that that I've heard from different
hosts of different shows and even some
of the you know like the executives at
fox is like Tulsa we really like having
you on because we never know what you're
gonna say literally you are you are
unpredictable and and that's why our
audience likes you because you're you
you're interesting person you have
something interesting to say that's not
just like one party's talking points or
you know whatever the popular thing is
of the day and I think that that says
something about media as a whole but the
fact that they they just say come on and
say your peace I go on and say my piece
whether the host agrees or disagrees
maybe that's part of the conversation
but it's not it's not the deciding
factor of of whether they have me on or
not but the other news networks it was a
deciding fact oh absolutely I mean I I
lots of people on social media like oh
how come you're always on Fox News you
know you're letting them take advantage
of you and all this other stuff it's
like no I'm taking advantage of the
platform number one because they reach
millions of people more than any other
Cable News Network and number two
CNN and MSNBC they don't they they
haven't asked me on their air for years
on any issue like Eve I reached out once
on Veterans issues toxic burn pits
things things that I've worked on in
Congress and still really passionate
about and trying to advance no interest
whatsoever
that's like
kind of crazy isn't it yeah it's very
revealing very revealing so you would
reach out to CNN and say hey I would
like to talk to you about the veterans
that have been around these toxic burn
pits and now they've got diseases would
you like to do this and you'd be like no
the response I got back and this was
that was the last time I reached out the
response I got back was like oh
interesting let me check with the
producers
and then radio silence like they didn't
have the balls to come back and say like
yeah no thanks not interested it was
just like no response
well you have your own platform now
right you got the the podcast the
YouTube channel
um
the the sub stack thing going on Tulsi
gabbard.com
um I'm working on a book right now as
well
um two books actually focused on
while at the Democratic party and the
other book focused on the cost of war or
do you already have a publisher for
these I do sweet and so one of these
things coming out
uh working on the sequencing uh but I
hope to have uh one of the books out by
I don't know early next year spring
what about politics
in your face I don't know I don't know
is the honest answer it's um
I want
to be in a position where I can best
make a positive impact and where I feel
I can best serve
I am
terribly concerned for all of the
reasons that we've talked about today
about
the failure it's not even a lack of
leadership it's it's it's a sincere
failure of leadership uh in this country
and
um
if there is a way for me to
actually directly impact that leadership
then I will pursue that whether that
means I'm running for office or
trying to impact those who are in office
we'll see
the the vehicle is is uh less important
than the impact to me
but you may go back into politics sure
[Laughter]
uh all right what is it Echo yes what do
you got anything else not I was gonna
ask that you were running for anything
or you know thinking about it or what
but you know we got that answer oh we're
still surfing obviously yes I'd like but
no how much are you traveling man is
alive as well a lot lately a lot I've
been on the road in the last two months
I've probably been home uh I don't know
two weeks out of that period of time you
spend a lot of time campaigning for
people too yes which was you know after
I announced that I was leaving the
Democratic party becoming an independent
um my phone started ringing off the hook
from people in what you know what they
call the swing States the states that
can either go democrat or republican a
lot of close races and people
invited me to come out and help campaign
for them
recognizing that there are a lot of
undecided people whether they're
Independents Or democrats Republicans or
frustrated with the current state of
affairs and current leadership
um and so yeah I I reached out to you
mostly Democrats or Republicans
Republicans did any Democrats reach out
to you no
if they had if there were if there were
a Democrat running for congress
who was openly calling out the insanity
of the Democrat leadership of today
and taking a strong stand on the things
we're talking about on just basic
fundamentals of freedom I would have
happily gone and campaigned for them
uh not a single one reached out and I've
been looking I've been looking for for
those those courageous voices to
actually step out and unfortunately
um
that hasn't been there
and I I've heard from some people
privately
just and then and really over over the
last few years who are saying hey thank
you so much for speaking out on these
things I appreciate what you're doing
but also don't tell anyone
and so it's it's sad it's unfortunate
but part of like the the last thing I
said in my announcement of leading the
Democratic party is I invite other I
invite other Democrats uh to join me as
anyone
not yet
all right so
um I guess we should real quick talk
about supporting this podcast of course
you're going to support Tulsa's podcast
but if you want to support this podcast
you want to support America and you want
to support yourself you can you can do
it we got a bunch of different ways for
you to do it how has your uh energy
drink been love it
so you immediately went for a mango
flavor which is the I mean is it safe to
say this is more of a Hawaiian Vibe yeah
especially with the Lily Queen there AKA
passion fruit okay so we got a little
bit of that going on um you can get this
stuff
from Dr fuel.com
you can get it at Wawa you can get it at
Vitamin Shop you can get it we're in all
military commissaries I've noticed that
I was in the commissary at Kaneohe
Marine Corps Base yes uh a week and a
half ago and I almost took a picture I
was like hey there's a chocolate fuel
we're about to be in the exchanges too
which is cool because if you're in the
military you know the commissaries
basically families go to commissaries
like the young enlisted guys they're not
going to the commissary it takes too
much time or whatever but they go to the
exchange exchange you know they sell gas
and whatever beer yeah so now you can
get some Jocko fuel you will be able to
in the very near future but um how do
you like is there a like red taped
process to get into like there is so
like like I was at the I was at a shot
done shot the other I don't know
whatever and they're like hey bring
those energy drinks we want to sell them
or whatever I can't just be like oh I
got something at home and bring them
right or can wait which store was it
like a local yeah yeah San Diego
Discount Gun Mart
yeah we just we did we did go wholesale
so if anybody wants to do wholesale this
is like if you got a store you got a gym
you got a A Jiu Jitsu Academy you can go
to JF sales at jocofuel.com and email
that and you get a wholesale account set
up and and that then you can do it okay
so is more for the the store really
right yeah yeah a little bit but not
really I mean when somebody wants to
bring something into their store they
can just get a wholesale account set up
now if they have a big chain store
that's where it run that's where you run
into and at some point I got to do some
kind of a podcast about what it goes on
that'd be interesting because for
instance
we're so it's kind of cool it's kind of
complementary when you start making a
dent
all of a sudden the big the big giant
billion dollar corporations realize that
you're making a dent and they come after
you so for instance
I don't know how much I can say about
this but I'll say a little bit uh in one
particular store that we're in one of
the big companies came in and paid
millions of dollars millions of dollars
for our slots in in this particular
store and like slots meaning room on the
Shelf room on the Shelf interesting they
said we really don't want Jocko fuel to
be out there we don't we see what
they're doing we see their growth we
don't like it we have to go on the
offense and so they paid millions and
millions of dollars to take our Shelf
space from us and and I can't even be
mad at the store because the store is
trying to make profit and they're trying
to do what they're doing and they also
have to keep a relationship with the big
giant companies otherwise they won't be
able to supply things that those big
giant companies put out there so
that's what happens that's the fight
we're in right now it's kind of cool
because it means you're you're you're
growing to a point where and people the
weird thing is people kind of all these
big companies and when I say big
companies
I'm not mincing any I'm talking about
the biggest companies there are they
know what we're doing they're they're
now taking active countermeasures to try
and shut us down because they know that
kind of on a on a product
we they can't beat us because we held
the line we're making it good for you
we're doing all these things that
they're not going to do they would
rather sacrifice millions of dollars to
buy that shelf space than pay create a
better create a better product
so that says a lot about competition
that's what we're up against and cool
like this is it this is what we're doing
um and we're gonna have some setbacks
like that but the cool thing is
the product is better we know it's
better they know it's better otherwise
they would just go Toe to Toe right oh
yeah just be like cool let's do this but
they don't want to do that Matt there
there are some interesting parallels to
what we were talking about about
substance versus trying to silence or
push out anybody who has a counter yeah
same I mean you're seeing it play out
you've seen it play now and but it is
crazy and that's why big corporations
with Bill with a B billions of dollars
they do their best to destroy
the smaller companies that are growing
and that's the way it is and we'll see
how it plays out I can tell you how it's
playing out right now it's playing out
good because we're going to continue to
make the best product we're going to
continue to grow and the cool thing is
the demand signal the demand signal
that's what like in this particular
store that I'm talking about and it's a
it's a whole group of stores but they
they took some slots the big billion
dollar Corporation took some slots but
the store wouldn't give up all of them
they took some but they said hey man
people aren't here every day for that
Jocko fuel we're not giving this up
we're not taking this away from our
customers yeah we can't just screw over
our customers we can screw them over a
little bit
but we can't screw them all the way over
so they kept a bunch of a bunch of our
product in the store but not as much as
we wanted but it's fine it's fine so if
you want to support America
and you want to support the growing
companies you want to support people
that are growing things in America then
jockofuel.com it's the same thing with
origin USA originusa.com and by the way
next time you're in North Carolina you
got to go to our Factory I know I've
been talking to Pete yeah and I think we
we may have something planned in
December we'll see good origin I was
supposed to go down there I was supposed
to go to the North Carolina Factory for
Veterans Day instead I went to the main
Factory because there's a freaking
hurricane hitting North Carolina so I
couldn't go down there but yeah next
time you're down there it's the same
thing yeah the billion dollar
corporations see what we're doing the
weird thing is they they're they saw
what we were doing in like before we
were even doing very much they were
threatened
and I think it's I think it's because
the truth so threatening and when you
have someone that's like no actually you
can build this stuff in America and when
for years they say you can't do it you
can't do it you can't they're they're
they're lying
and so now there's someone saying oh
yeah look at this over here look what
we're actually doing right now 100 in
America look and they they are scared
and so since day one they've been on to
us the the
food companies they're kind of taking
notice in the last six months where
they're like oh [__]
the the clothing companies they've been
honest because they're scared because
we're doing everything right and they're
doing everything wrong and that's just
all there is to I think they recognize
too kind of the difference between the
you know the fast fashion just buying
like the cheap stuff use it a few times
then throw it away versus
the conscious choice that I think a lot
of people are starting to make is like
okay I might pay a few more dollars
but I will take pride in knowing that in
Origins case from the cotton that's
grown to the final hands that are
putting those jeans in a bag
these were American hands that and hard
work and sweat that went into creating
this and I will wear this with pride
yeah and by the way
that hard work these are people that
have mortgages that are learning like we
God
kids I shouldn't call them kids but you
know people that are 23 years old 22
years old that now have a skill that
they have a career now
whether it's running a loom whether it's
running a a press whatever skill they're
getting they're getting a skill that
they can now have they have a real job
they have a career they have a life so
that's what you're supporting also
environmentally this is America exactly
we treat the environment well those
factories that you're buying from
overseas especially from these companies
that claim to be environmental companies
and they're producing their stuff why
are they producing their stuff overseas
because overseas they don't have the
regulations they don't have the
environmental regulations that we have
to abide by which we do gladly because
we care about the environment we care
about the water right we care about the
nature we care about animals that's what
we do and and so these big companies
they know that we're right and they are
so horrified that the words getting out
the words getting out that we're here
we're doing it they're horrified if you
want to help that out originusa.com get
something
that you're gonna wear for the next 18
years exactly you're gonna wear a pair
of jeans for 14 years you can wear a
pair of these boots for ever they might
be forever I mean how long are you gonna
live maybe you live to be 100 right but
you're going to use a jiu jitsu gi
get get one gee get two geese you can
use them forever yeah and by the way our
Jiu Jitsu you can wash it in a normal
washing machine it doesn't take nine
hours to dry out like we're in a totally
different world yeah plus it's Christmas
coming up Christmas is coming up
Christmas coming up and
the economy we all know the economy
needs help yeah well how do you help the
economy when you buy something from
origin you're helping the economy here
in America there's a worker that's
getting paid that's earning their career
that's paying their rent paying their
mortgage because of that
and then what do they do they take that
paycheck and they put it back into
America it's like that's what we're
doing
so
originusa.com yep speaking of stuff
speaking of Christmas sometimes you want
to get a shirt or something you know
there's people representing I'm telling
you you want a discipline equals Freedom
shirt or Hatter hoodie whatever go to
Chocolate store.com yeah speaking of
which my youngest daughter yes
um is wrestling at this time you know
it's wrestling season we need some rash
guards for her you know just I got you
to kind of make that happen yeah yeah we
got a few rash guards on there she wants
to represent yeah on the path I'll get
you a shirt too all right I don't have
one already he gets you a tank top
something like that also shirt Locker
it's a subscription scenario where you
get to share it every month some good
stuff coming out no free dopamine it's
gonna be a good one that one kind of get
some traction on that huh I like that no
free dopamine there's some good ones on
there good thing too if you sign up no
matter when you sign up you have access
to all the past shirts like if you think
oh you missed out or something like that
you got access to that when you sign up
so whatever you need Jocko store.com you
know again like back in the day when I
was a kid if you had some kind of crazy
sort of movement in your life that you
wanted to make a statement about let's
get a t-shirt bro yeah yeah it's getting
any kind of surgery
put your statement on the T-shirt we're
a destiny goes Freedom T-shirt there you
go and if you in in in eight years if
you decide you know what I'm not really
all about that discipline anymore cool
you get a different t-shirt let's get
some donuts right let's stick with that
there's an anti-donut shirt coming out
too by the way sherlocker wow that's
controversial man this highly
controversial yeah that one was kind of
hard to pull off you know because it's
like how do you well then again there's
a lot of ways to do it but I think we
got it
Donuts look again for me and I get it I
get that there's two sides to every
controversial thing in the world but I
just can't support Donuts I can't ever
like never ever I can't do it so let me
ask you this like so like every once in
a great while
everyone's in a group well like when I
finished
uh Day Zero of air assault School in
Hawaii I was like heck yeah I'm gonna
give me some donuts I earned this [__]
once in a great while yep I I get it
what's what's your once in a great while
um and chocolate chip ice cream okay and
and and straight just chocolate chip
cookies all right and you know by the
way if you're out there and you're gonna
send chocolate chip cookies just or
cookies to someone just send them
chocolate chip cookies
don't send them peanut butter cookies
definitely don't send them oatmeal
raisin cookies because oatmeal raisin
cookies look at first glance I got
chocolate too please
what is the point what is the point so
you might as well eat oatmeal right
come on
come on there there are two kind there's
two foods that I I don't like oatmeal
and cooked carrots
just those are just two things I'm not
really picky otherwise but oatmeal and
cook carrots I'm not happening so Ryan
Jobe is asking a Bruiser God God bless
him
um
he he was killed
um or he's wounded in Iraq died of
wounds he had he hated uh cottage cheese
and so the smell of cottage cheese he
would start gagging
and there was a time he was getting
uh
let's say some some counseling from his
platoon and he was under a kangaroo
court right and they're like you know
Bagels his nickname was Bagels Bagels
you know if you really love I forget
what it was but something like you know
if you really love the teams you're
gonna eat this cottage cheese and like
they're spooning it through his mouth
and as he's go as it's going to his
mouth he's like and he's just choking it
down and throwing up it was freaking
hysterical uh so yeah counseling yeah
he's character receiving some character
building you gotta watch out that cup
but there's certain foods that do that
to some people yeah and apparently it's
cooked carrots yeah I just don't like
them the thing that I um that has that
effect like that physical effect is
actually
um
bananas like I will throw frozen bananas
in my smoothies banana bread great but I
think it was because in basic training
like I I mean it was you you will eat
one banana with every meal
um because of whatever just prevent
cramping like I don't know whatever it
was and it just it literally got to a
point where I was just like like the gag
reflex was so I I to this day I don't I
won't eat that's crazy huh because the
the banana in the milkshake is that's
the Tulsi Jammer oh no the Frozen Frozen
yeah totally fine yeah I I won't
actually I owe you money on that like
yeah
we've been propping up the Tulsi frozen
banana fruit yeah it adds just that
little bit of cream and I love it I love
it but it's just like that the fresh
there was I was on deployment I was on a
ship on deployment
no war going on We're just trying to get
jacked and there was this this protein
shake that was Vanilla
and I was drinking it like breakfast
lunch and dinner trying to put on
games right and it was by the time
probably it's probably two months into a
six month deployment I I had to hold my
nose and drink it like it was just shot
a tequila just like oh it made me want
maybe my phone had that kind of that
kind of gave me like the kind of pts
banana PTSD you're talking about it's
more the association yeah even to this
day vanilla is not one of my favorites
just because of that one six month
period of choking down you know when you
go on deployment and you have like a
like a palette and it's just filled with
one flavor you know you're screwed
totally especially because on the ship
like the food kind of sucks and if
you're not getting good you got to get
your protein from somewhere so there you
go but he well he can't technical back
to the donuts thing room he can't
Advocate even for uh moderation I
painted myself into a corner yeah yes I
painted myself into a cornrows probably
the one of the few things in the the
world other than if you or Isis we're
not going to get along the other one is
like I can't really decide hey maybe
Donuts are okay on this occasion even
when people have like protein Donuts you
know what I'm talking about yeah like
nutrition solutions they make protein
Donuts I'm sure they're good to go yeah
and I'm sure they're they're they're
like in compliance with the path yeah
but I I just can't do it because it's a
moral victory for the donor yeah
you declared anti-donut early on too
hard yeah yeah so you cannot just like
like how you
[Music]
or is it just hey I'm gonna just
maintain the path here oh yeah this is a
good point I don't know it's like but
there's that other part too though just
like the alcohol you know Holly you're
like hey I can't advocate for alcohol at
all well even though we all know that
hey most people in moderation then
they're not gonna have problems but you
start advocating for donuts alcohol or
whatever some people like charcoal said
it's okay yeah so they start freaking
pounding Donuts every week you know
because moderation can be subjective yes
exactly I'll only eat five a week
instead of all right left today than I
did yesterday so whatever you know wait
you're vegan right yeah and now are
donuts vegan some are and there is a
pop-up in Hawaii
that only opens up for four hours on the
weekends and it's first come first serve
and they usually sell out in the first
hour vegan donuts and they are I will
show you pictures afterward they are the
most
Heavenly luxuriously like oh my gosh you
just look at it and it's like a whole
meal in One Donut it's like yeah it's
it's a totally different where did you
get your protein from
um I take uh I I drink protein shakes
every day uh and it's primarily coming
from a pea protein source
um I used to do whey protein but how
long have you been a vegan for
probably the last I don't know four or
five years vegetarian my whole life and
then ethical reasons environmental
reasons spiritual reasons all of the
above have you had a steak before no
[Music]
that response is the response that I've
gotten most often especially in the
military but it's like
um it's not it's not something I've ever
had so it's like you saying that I have
no desire whatsoever
Rogan I met Rogan for uh lunch or dinner
whatever one day with some of his
friends and
they went to what's the what's the
Brazilian Fogo de Chao and wrote I it
was he didn't really comment it on the
time but he mentioned recently in a
podcast he's like we went there and all
she ate was salad how is that even
possible but it's just it's not
something you know there's no
there's no craving I guess
that's interesting you guys just discuss
because you know with diet pottery's
kids
um I think exercise might be another one
religion and politics those are the the
hot button subjects so we're covering
all of it yeah but this is the one you
guys are opposed though that's the thing
but I think I think this is this is like
a good example though because it's one
thing to say you know like hey this is
my choice for my life and my lifestyle
I'm not trying to go around saying every
single person in the world has to follow
my exact life choices in all of those
examples if we hung out more like if if
I moved back to Hawaii and uh and we
were hanging out more would you kind of
start to be like hey you know man why
are you eating all that steak do you
think you would to try and help me
uh not unless you were saying hey Tulsi
I feel like [__] and my body's not
functioning what would you advise or
what's working for you but otherwise no
that's kind of good because then that's
what I was thinking too as you were
saying I was thinking if you said to me
like hey I don't feel that good I feel
lethargic I'd be like hey we're going
out for steak
uh all right
um what else Echo Charles so that's the
shirt lockers and stuff like this
subscribe uh Jocko underground.com
this is the platform that we made in
case we get kicked off of other
platforms straight up that's what's
going on that's the reality yeah of what
we face and so if you go to Jocko
underground.com you can get on that
platform it costs eight dollars and 18
cents a month how did you choose that
number by the way I've always been
curious should we
is it an area code thing or no we'll
actually put it this way there was the
first reason the primary reason and then
there's like a secondary reason that
that shuffled like right in there as
well the secondary reason is uh from the
Bible it's like current sufferings don't
outweigh future Glory something like
this and then but the primary reason was
Hardcore recondos yeah it's HR okay
eight letter in the and the 18th which
we've which we've never divulged until
this moment wow so that's what it is the
Hardcore condos both of those are pretty
powerful
there we are yep and look if you can't
afford that which I get it's tight times
and they're gonna get tighter there's a
recession
you're not allowed to say there's a
recession coming I think there are a lot
of economists who would agree with you
uh if times get too tight and you can't
afford it just to email email assistance
at jockleunderground.com we'll get you
hooked up there
you and check out tulsi's Sub sub stack
yep really just Google sub staff let's
see if you go on sub stack and you just
put in Tulsi or Tulsi yeah
[Music]
um almost everything I put up is not
behind a paywall
um if you want to kind of get in on the
conversation I think it's like six bucks
a month or something how'd you come up
with that number six bucks a month
uh it's just the average of what's out
there I don't have a Bible verse to back
it up
clearly a missed opportunity all right
you know I've just giving you that
opportunity then YouTube we got the
Jocko podcast YouTube channel yep and
origin USA YouTube channel and then the
Tulsi gabbard show I think is your
YouTube channel yep yeah subscribe to
everywhere everywhere you get your
podcasts
um these platforms are growing they're
new and so for people if you watch or
you listen and you like it uh subscribe
leave a rating and and share it with
others that's the plan psychological
warfare is out there you need that that
Jocko uh influence maybe I need some
Jocko uh discipline to make a new one of
those right yeah it's been a while Anita
asked me some of those questions what's
good for the goose is good good for this
guy flipsidecanvas.com Dakota Meyer's
company bunch of books a bunch of I've
written a bunch of books
only cry for the living
um
finally okay great great Christmas gifts
oh and then people are looking I mean
you know it's like I you know when I
think of gifts that I want to give
people
they should be Gifts of meaning and
substance ideally rather than just
something that is cheap and can be
easily thrown away and become part of a
landfill somewhere yeah that's what I
think you know books are good these
books are are fantastic some of the
things you're talking about earlier
because for me I I actually you know you
can get audio books and you know ebooks
and all that but I'm one of those people
who like if I'm taking notes and getting
ready for a TV interview
I'll look at what's on the computer and
then I actually sit there and actually
write it down there's something about
reading words on the page that you can
keep going back to you can highlight you
can kind of bend the the corner of the
page over and know that that's something
that you can use
and keep going back to it yeah I am a
huge physical books Guy and
um
there's definitely some sort of rote
memorization that happens or absorption
that happens when you write stuff down
you highlight it and all that stuff so
yeah you get all these books for
Christmas for somebody and they can
really help I'll tell you what honestly
just get to get the kids you know get
the kids you know the warrior kid books
yep just to help them with life it'll
help them in so many different ways and
there's so much look we spent the first
I don't know 40 minutes today talking
about all the negative influence that
there is out there on kids and social
media don't let them be exposed to that
or if they do get exposed to it let them
have some kind of a grounding and a
foundation to Think Through what's going
on and get on the right path as a human
being weigh the warrior kid one two
three four five is coming by the way oh
damn yeah called letters from Uncle Jake
so there you go Echelon front leadership
consultancy go to ashlandfront.com for
details if you need help inside your
organization whatever organization that
is
let us know we can help you we have some
Live Events Orlando April 3rd through
the 5th and Dallas October 18th through
the 20th we've sold out every one of
these that we've ever done so if you
want to go
get in early
um we have online training extreme
ownership.com it's an online platform
training in leadership
leadership is not something you learn in
the day you can't just go to tulsi's
Army course on leadership and like oh
now you're good to go it's not going to
happen no offense to Tulsi but it takes
more than that you're gonna have it's
gonna take time so if you it's like
going to the gym if you want to go to
the gym for leadership you want to go to
the gym for Life go to extreme
ownership.com if you want to help
service members active and retire
active and retired you want to help
their families gold star families check
out Mark Lee's mom mama Lee she's got a
charity organization
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to America's Mighty Warriors
dot org and also heroes and horses.org
where Micah Fink has taken
people up into the wilderness
so they can find themselves on Horseback
getting into the Wilderness so check
that out as well
if you want to connect with Tulsi on the
interwebs Tulsi gabbard.com
on social media on on Twitter on
Instagram on Facebook she's at Tulsi
gabbard on YouTube at Tulsi gabbard show
and she's got her podcast and she's got
her sub stack that we talked about so
check all that as well
and as far as Echo and I are concerned
echo's attic with Charles I am at Jocko
link but listen
the algorithm just watch out for the
algorithm because it is definitely
looking to grab you yeah and they're
looking to brainwash you
and if you go into it knowing that
they're looking to brainwash you that's
a good step in the right direction huge
but if you go into it thinking that
you're getting smarter
because of this that's a bad situation
that you're getting yourself into so
just please be careful be careful with
the social media use it
use it for something positive though
and only use it for a limited amount of
time all right please
there you go Tulsi
any closing thoughts for us
um God we covered a lot
it's great to see you guys great to be
back
um
yeah I I just to add on to what you just
said you know don't underestimate the
power of your own voice
understand the responsibility that each
of us has on the impact that we make in
the world and know that the choices we
make every day
can lead to having a positive or
negative impact
so be an independent thinker be
discerning
and be intentional with the choices that
you make both for yourself and for those
around you
sounds like a plan
um thanks for joining us again I'm sure
we'll see you again thanks for your
service in the Army thanks for your
service in Congress
thanks for your service in America and
now I guess thank you for your service
to the world as you try and help people
by spreading Aloha worldwide
and uh thanks to all of our service
members around the world in the Army
Navy Air Force Marines thank you for
protecting our freedom same goes here at
home to our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
Secret Service all First Responders
thanks for what you do on a daily basis
to keep us safe here at home
and everyone else out there
the world is a crazy place right now and
it will drive you crazy
if you let it
my recommendation
is that you remain sane
that you stay balanced that you don't
let Bots
or provocateurs or trolls get into your
head
instead listen but question what you
hear trying to understand what's going
on and then go do some jiu jitsu
and then like Tulsi
go spread some of that Aloha spirit and
until next time this is Tulsi and Echo
and Jocko out